Well,
hey everybody,
what the fuck is going on in internet land?
My friends today,
it's going to be a lot of fun.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's
o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
shroom,
tech,
sport and shroom,
immune and new mood.
We got some supplements for your brain,
son.
If you're interested in nootropics,
in all seriousness,
that's what Alpha brain is.
It's a blend of nutrients that are supposed to enhance your brain's ability to
produce neurotransmitters.
They make you essentially,
they make you a little bit smarter.
Does it work?
Yeah,
it works.
Yeah.
There's,
I've,
I've been experimenting with nootropics and so as a young man and,
uh,
there's,
there's a,
there's been a lot of,
um,
different formulas that have come out like a,
there's a guy named Bill Roman house.
You,
no,
we as a former football player get,
uh,
get right up in the [inaudible] before.
Yeah.
Well,
he,
uh,
he suffered a lot of concussions.
This is where I found out about it.
He suffered a lot of concussions and he um,
started taking different nutrients that are designed to sort of stimulate your
brain function and he created his own sort of blend of him and it's called neuro
one.
And that's how I got into nootropics from his stuff.
Have you ever seen them make like a really stupid motherfucker,
I can't do this,
can't do that.
You know what it does is it,
it,
it honestly for me it feels like things like things come a little smoother,
if that makes any sense.
It's like there's,
I know there's levels of brain function and you,
so you've got to figure out,
well what is that?
What is it?
What are the,
what are the levels of brain function?
What is it?
When I wake up in the morning and I just feel like I fucking dummy,
my brain is foggy.
I don't know what's going on.
Like if I do an interview at like eight o'clock in the morning,
I sound like a fucking idiot.
It takes me a while to like get that brain cooking.
So these more for like powers of retention,
then things that are already in your mind.
So your memory's just quick on something like that.
It's,
I have no idea if they say that people retain everything are usually a huge
amount of what they see every day.
And that is just subconscious.
So maybe what these things are doing or maybe what they're starting to be able
to do is to pull those memories straight forward because we have so much
information in our mind.
I don't know anyone that's,
that's a huge stretch.
I don't know.
You'd have to be a scientist to even with that.
I think what it is is,
you know,
there's,
how long have you been to these Alpha brain?
I think that we'd been out for like two years now.
That's what I'm saying.
We're at the very,
very beginning of something like this then.
Well,
uh,
there's a been a bunch of different studies on all sorts of different nootropics
and uh,
some really positive results are starting to come back.
There's,
um,
a new additive that we put into Alpha brain.
I don't even know the name of the new shit.
If you're interested in any of this stuff,
go to [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n,
I t and all.
It's all explained in detail,
but whatever this new shit that we just put into Alpha brain,
that's the technical term for it.
It,
uh,
has been shown to improve golfers.
I don't know all of these
different things that they do.
Is it just if every it has everything firing on,
uh,
like,
like all the right points?
You know what I mean?
If it makes me feel like the difference between when I take and I don't take it
is sort of like the difference between not having a cup of coffee and having a
cup of coffee,
but not really because it's not like an addictive feeling.
It's not like a,
um,
like if I don't like I get really excited about having coffee,
I can't wait to have it and then I get it,
I'm like,
oh,
it's like a little fixed for me.
It's probably not good for you.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's,
I mean,
it's definitely this p they say it's okay if you drink a cup of day,
but really why is it okay if you drink a cup of tea?
I mean,
why is it okay to take a certain amount of stimulants?
is it really,
you know,
I'm not really sure,
but it's not much of anything makes you an addict,
but the Alpha brain doesn't make you feel stupid when it's over.
It's not like you have an app and then as it down just gets everything loose.
It's a fascinating subject and there's a lot of controversy,
but there's a lot of studies and a lot of very promising studies and we're a,
we're going to do our own.
Eventually we're just formulating the final,
the final,
a formulation of the,
uh,
of the blend.
And the most recent one is the one that I liked the best.
And um,
it's hard to tell the difference.
So to be honest with you,
it's like,
maybe I'm just eating better now too.
There's a lot of different things that come into factor when it comes to the way
your brain works.
And that's something that everybody needs to consider.
You know,
if you really want those and then you on Meth as nothing else.
Yeah,
it's not going to help you.
I think the most important thing that any,
any,
anybody could ever emphasize is it take care of your,
your body,
take care of your meat vessel,
take care of this thing that's taking you through life.
Don't fuck with it too much man.
You know?
I mean,
you should be careful with what you eat.
If you eat sugar every day and crap every day and you're fucking with your body
man,
you're fucking with that thing.
You just given it so you're not getting what it needs and it's going to have
some misfires and it's going to have some malfunction.
And then you need to realize that,
that the age old saying once a man twice a baby,
you know what I mean?
And what does that mean?
Even our,
sure you come into this world,
you know,
naked,
defenseless,
and when you see very elderly people,
and I think this gives me a great respect for all that they've been through in
life.
A lot of times they need help or they can't move or something like that and
they're dependent on somebody else to take care of them.
And that,
that seeing that vision is supposed to inspire like humility and people to be
like,
Yo,
you know what?
Oh Man.
Instead of you see people honking their horn,
like walk faster so I can get to nowhere.
You know what I'm saying?
People honking horns at old people in New York.
Crazy.
They're out of control,
man.
I mean everybody,
I'm from New York where people are in a rush to go nowhere.
You're,
you're rushing from work to get back home to let cable TV wash over you and do
nothing.
Well,
it's because the idea of New York's ridiculous.
What a silly idea packed out how many motherfuckers,
you know,
one small let that ride from a Boston dude,
man.
But I,
I,
I'm telling you right now,
I'm sort of a Boston do,
but I was born in,
so I'm more
of a,
it's even more fun.
Ravelry it's cold.
It just seems crazy.
It's a crazy idea to stuff that many people that,
you know what I thought about the exact same day I went to uh,
to do a tour in Australia and New Zealand and I came home and it just dawned on
me like,
I'm,
people think,
oh,
you're so smart.
Tech man car,
you'd think about somebody read all this stuff.
I came home and it dawned on me,
damn,
a human being's natural habitat is not a square of concrete and steel.
Like this is not healthy.
You go around in New York,
you see trees in cages.
They're like,
oh,
there's the park.
I was like,
yeah,
good.
A reservation for trees.
You know what I mean?
Without that,
there wouldn't be no oxygen in the city.
It's a weird energy that you get from only people and the things that people
have created.
It's like an artificial world,
like a completely different construct.
It's a city state.
It's a weird place.
I love it,
man.
I bet you do.
I,
you know I'm still there.
There.
No,
you don't.
Some people love that shit.
My manager loves it.
He wouldn't live anywhere else.
Anyway,
I'm going to [inaudible] dot com to check out if you're interested in interested
in any new tropics,
I just suggest you Google the subject.
There's a lot of controversy.
There's a lot of uh,
unsubstantiated claims,
but there's a lot of real good research that points to the fact that different
nutrients can improve mental function and we've combined the best,
the best formulation that we know how to make.
And uh,
if you're interested in it and you try it,
there's a 100% money back guarantee for the first 30 pills.
So if you try it and you don't like it,
you don't feel it,
you get your money back.
You don't even have to send in the product.
We were much more concerned with people not feeling ripped off than we are with
making money.
I just know that you're going to enjoy it.
It's the Shit I turned all my friends onto it.
Not One of them is not an Alpha brain head.
Now it's this shit that sounds terrible and Alpha brain.
That's so douchey.
Come apologize.
I apologize.
Yeah,
it comes to the pill.
Don't snort it.
You freaks.
I was just going to say after the show,
me and Joe and crushed that shit up.
Rolling the L.
Yeah,
that's the seat.
What if that was the secret?
The whole time I've got this Alpha brain and the,
I didn't even know about it.
That you're suspicious of snort it.
Yeah.
Snoring it.
You're better off.
Um,
we also have a kettle bells and battle ropes in now.
I did my first battle work battle a rope work today.
That things crazy.
It's really weird.
Yeah,
I'll do it.
I will,
we'll uh,
we're gonna make some videos too because people keep asking the different
exercises.
What kettlebells are is,
um,
it's an ancient Russian form of strength training.
It's like a cannon ball attached to the handle.
It's the most manly shit you could ever be involved with in your life.
Okay.
There's swinging around a fucking cannon ball and if it comes to working out,
it's like for me,
I think it's the best strength training work that a,
you could do when it comes to like real world application.
Like your ability to like,
like the,
the strength that really comes up in the real world.
It's like dead lifts,
strength and squat strength and bench press trank that's like real world,
you know?
But there's a lot of people out there like doing curls and tricep extension,
right.
Never going to be like sitting trying to push.
It's kind of silly.
I mean the Russian fashion weights,
I know it dude that used to do nothing but those,
yeah.
He was like,
look,
if I'm lifting something like this,
yeah.
This is like if all I do is this and that there's no power in my arm to pull
something up like this.
And I've been doing this with 40 pound weights for years.
Like it definitely gave him a different type of strength than I've seen other
people,
I think more centered in the body that I didn't,
you know,
it's true.
I mean,
well it gives you a lot,
but it certainly strengthens your core,
which is like one of those words that people like to use a lot.
You've got to work on your core strength,
your core,
you know,
it becomes some sort of a weird sort of a classification for exercise.
But what's important is the whole thing has to work.
Everything has to work and sometimes do to fuck up and they developed like big
arms and shit and a big chest,
but their legs don't work that good or you know,
they,
you know,
they don't have good lower back strength cause they're,
they're doing silly exercises.
They're not,
they're not bouncing out their body.
And the best thing about Kettlebell exercises you can do with just one of these
cannonballs.
You can literally the workout,
every muscle in your body and you,
it's the kind of workout that you get.
The only thing that's as exhausting is doing Jujitsu.
To me,
that's the only thing that gets me is tired,
is actually sparring and training.
It's,
it's such a brutal workout.
There's a great DVD to fall called extreme kettlebell cardio workout that dragon
door carries.
If you can get through this motherfucker's workout with a 35 pound kettle bell,
you're an animal and that sounds like nothing.
It's like,
what a 35 pound dude,
40 minutes into this thing you were ready to die.
It's incredible.
How tired again,
check it out.
It's the shit.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com and check it out.
If you use a code name Brogan,
you could save 10% off supplements.
But we,
uh,
we literally can't sell kettlebells any cheaper than we're sending them.
We're,
we're basically sending cannon balls in the mail.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It's,
it's hard to get a maid.
They're,
they're,
they're made by Troy and they're the best kettle bells that we could buy.
We,
we,
you know,
we've found the best shit and we're selling it for the best price that we can.
These things though are bulletproof.
They will last forever.
They will find them after the Armageddon and there'll be at the bottom of the,
the new ocean and they'll go,
what does this fucking cannon ball with a handle on it.
So you buy them.
Once you got them for life and literally you,
you might not ever need to go to a gym again.
You can do almost anything except Chin ups,
you know?
That's the only thing that I would say.
It's a between Chin ups,
body weight squats,
and a couple of kettle bells.
That's like all the equipment you ever need go to on a dotcom.
Check it all out.
You dirty for probably good for murder
or also you could probably kill somebody with him.
She could probably
just that as a weapon.
You could use it as a weapon.
Keep it by your bed.
If somebody breaks in,
Brian,
you can use sex as a weapon.
So Julissa,
pap editor,
you know,
I imagine that I'm somebody breaks and listen.
If you don't leave my house right now,
I'm going to fuck you.
Yeah.
I'm going to shoot you in the legs and I'm going to fuck you afterwards.
That's really got to scare the shit of daddy body though.
Yeah,
that would be not what you expect to hear.
You could totally throw somebody off.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
immortal technique is here.
We're going to get shipped.
Poppin yeah,
yeah.
Well,
good experience my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night,
all day.
You gonna hit that music.
Yeah,
right.
Oh
my truth is the all [inaudible] Ethiopia,
Ethiopian,
the want you to fuck with a Minneapolis Somali,
you know when I go home,
the world I used to know was going in Napa live on my own for what shall it,
profit or wrapper.
We creative control to sign a deal with the devil and who was his sole Musto
Porn?
First expression is cold like the faces,
the slave map just on the paper folds.
It's a blip and no racial supremacy quick like the bedtime stories.
Joseph Smith got it for me.
Plot to murder my seeds,
a shorty put them in the now in a basket of reason.
That was Dave to the future.
What is triggered to flashlight wondering who to fuck with me in a past life,
bad diet or die young,
fast life.
Same as a credit flight that took off with the music God on your last night and
some of the truth and they caught you a trader.
Honestly,
any code you will hate.
Hater moves the mock composure
messages are looking at it as bad as you want to hear the whole.
Yeah.
Or pick somewhere we can deep into cross their wings against the head that the
reason that he did with nothing left to believe and even a reason for living
that was forgiven by God and not religion with them from the tent like hoarders
tend the Baptist church,
the chicken off the rigor mortis supporters should be illegal instead of the
people that were you here before the Bible.
The more I speak to the detached,
an unrealistic that before,
normally
we resisted the whole insecurities Michigan because I didn't know what they
really get fishing.
Hi.
First of all,
how bad ass is that lyric?
I am the eye,
the sky looking
at you.
I can read your mind.
You need to,
you need an acre of rules dealing with fools.
I can cheat you blind.
Have you done like an extended version of that song?
Because that song is like crack like I want,
I could hear like that for two more times.
Big shout out to my brother's Sao Paulo who's responsible for producing that.
It's off the CD.
I just gave you the mater.
It's free.
Like,
I had so many other things in this world.
Some people think that nothing's free,
but that actually is free.
You can go to viper records.com and you don't have to fill out a stupid survey.
You don't have to sit through a 15 second vivo commercial press one button and
then nine minutes later you have a 16 track album.
Absolutely free by mortal technique feature and a lot of hip hop,
underground grates and legends,
you know,
and we got,
um,
styles p from the locks,
Vinnie paths,
a poisoned pen.
Diaboliques swaves of a kid.
I mean,
I could just go on dead Prez and you decided to release it free.
Absolutely.
For free.
My brothers,
I'm killer.
Mike,
Chuck d brother Ali's on here.
Uh,
Joel Ots,
Pumpkin head at Cornell West is on here.
Just,
just so many.
I got,
he got Cornell west on your CD.
Yeah,
he's doing the outro for me.
Holy Shit.
That's awesome.
He's on,
he's on a movie out.
I'm pretty strong,
dude.
Wait a minute.
When you're a rapper,
you get Cornell west or your CD and he's only shit homie.
You know what I mean?
That's a,
that's a pretty impressive man.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
That's awesome.
That's bad ass.
So,
uh,
the,
the name of it again,
one more time for people who are listening,
the martyr,
the martyr viper records.com VIP are records.com what made you decide to put it
out for free?
Well,
I mean it was at a time when I saw that people were struggling financially,
economically and I thought to myself,
listen,
what's more revolutionary as opposed to being an artist that just has stuff
ghost written for him and then gives it out to people and he gets angry when
they download your terrible music.
You know,
what's more revolutionary than taking hardcore hip hop from the streets and then
music with a message combining them and give them to the people.
Absolutely.
For free.
100% plus they'd been waiting so long when it's other album,
I have called the middle passage that if I didn't give them something I would
have probably got killed and is a really,
I mean if you really think about it is the best thing you can.
I mean we always feel about this podcast that,
you know,
I would never want to charge for it.
Like part of the cool thing about it is that it's free.
Right?
Well,
I like doing it for free.
I like that you don't have to pay Shit and you,
oh,
it's not just that.
It's just like,
look,
if you really support what I said,
like the music then come to a show the same way.
Listen to the podcast and be like,
Yo,
if you like what we're doing here for free,
come see the show.
We are going to be live here.
We're going to be dead.
Blog was a blog.
Then that's what happens for the most part of my shows.
It's mostly a podcast fancies taste,
but it's the idea that you decided to just produce a whole CD and put it out
like that.
I agree that that's,
that's like that.
That is,
that seems to be the right thing to do.
I mean a lot of people are doing it now.
You've given it to him for free.
Of course.
They're like,
when you give people shit for free,
you know,
you develop the right kind of relationship,
you develop like a giving relationship,
you're giving and you know,
you create this sort of a mutually beneficial relationship with the people that
enjoy your shit.
So they actually enjoy,
you know,
the fact that that a lot of people find out about you,
they enjoy the fact that the music is good,
the enjoy the fact,
you know,
they get to be a part of it all.
I'll definitely,
I,
you know,
I didn't know the impact of what I did,
um,
up until like,
you know,
maybe a year or two into it,
I really started to get a grasp of it and then slowly accepted the
responsibility.
Um,
and I think there's a big difference in between being an independent artist and
being in charge of everything that you have to do in order to be successful and
then having,
you know,
a label babysit you through a three 60 deal with something like that.
You were completely independent.
Is that how it works?
I pressed up my own units and I have a distribution deal,
which means that that's about as independent as we can possibly be.
Me,
you know,
I'm completely ignorant about the music business.
I don't know nothing about it.
So explain to me like,
is it,
is it hard to did to get to the point where you're at,
like to be completely independent and have people know about you and like what
sort of distribution channels did you have to go through in order to remain
independent?
Well,
in the,
in the very beginning I had to find individuals that already had a distribution
deal because at that point I was just one artist and they weren't in the habit
of saying,
all right,
we're just going to sign an artist who doesn't have a roster.
It doesn't have a label.
Um,
so I found a friend of the family that had a very small label called viper
records and I was like,
Yo,
let's help build something here.
And eventually it led to a few distribution deals.
And now I'm at one where I feel,
you know,
I'm in the right place.
I have the right people on my side.
It's a much larger and more expansive one than I traditionally had before.
But just so people understand out there that may not know,
you know,
a record deal is essentially alone with horrible interest rates because you
know,
and even after a loan,
you know what happens when you get a bad loan and you ended up paying it all
off.
You'll get to keep the property blending.
In this case,
you don't keep your intellectual property,
your masters and your publishing are owned by somebody else.
And if you read the fine contract and legal ease and perpetuity,
and in some cases that's just doesn't make any sense to me.
I think that whole business has completely fallen apart,
right?
I mean,
well it is from business.
It's,
it's gone down to a personal appearance business.
It's become that more,
right?
Uh,
to to some extent,
I think that's why they implemented the three 60 deals.
So they felt like they could eat off the shows as opposed to the dwindling
revenue,
say three 60 deals.
What does that three 60 deal means?
That the label now collects on everything.
The ancillary rights,
you know,
if your music is in a movie,
if you do a show,
they're getting half of the show.
If you do a show,
you're getting like whatever you do,
like a reality show,
they get the money.
Whatever you do do,
if you do it,
if you were in a record in later,
what do you do?
Really?
So if you had like the immortal technique show and you know,
people traveled around when he was sideways three 64 they would take a piece of
that.
Yeah.
If they,
what are they offering though?
That's what,
that's what it depends on what status you have.
If you was someone who's built up an independent brand,
see,
I'll give you an example.
How did you do it?
If I have a good idea,
right.
And I say to you,
Joe,
you know,
as a company,
as,
as a gigantic,
a multinational conglomerate,
I got this company about people who get on the Internet and meet other people
that are similar and they get to post their pictures.
You're looking at me like,
ah,
yeah.
All right,
well,
how much is it going to sell?
And I'm,
I'm giving you numbers,
but let's say I set up something like my space,
which is obviously now not in its former glory,
but if I say,
all right,
well I have this company,
my space,
and it has,
you know,
I don't know 20 million people on it,
signed up,
look at the,
the advertising potential that we have here,
then I can suck.
Or somebody like Rupert Murdoch and the buying it for $500 million.
And I think it's just the same thing in music.
If you've already built up an independent fan base,
if you have something that's completely your own,
then you're coming to them with everything and you're saying,
listen,
I don't need to give you more than just this.
You know,
I will give you the small percentage,
which is usually between 15 and 25%,
um,
for just distributing the product,
making sure it's an oldest stores.
But isn't it almost everything distributed through electronic media now?
I mean,
I,
I think many actual cds move,
maybe I've sold maybe a about a quarter of million records of the four albums
that I've had out and I've moved about half of the product.
We own the last on the record in,
in physical,
not in digital.
So it's still about half and half still have,
we're talking about 40 to 60% of the revenue in certain ways.
And do you buy cds these days or do you download shit and then occasionally,
you know,
if I,
if I supported artist,
if I liked somebody and I think that dope and I there a friend of mine,
I go to the record store,
I'll buy one or two over.
Y'all never see a record.
Sure.
When the fuck I buy all my cds,
that Starbucks,
like I was saying,
I do that sometimes.
That's probably the less,
you know what?
I think you're right.
I think the last CD I bought was at Starbucks,
iTunes.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah,
I do.
I assume it's like almost all of my stuff is iTunes now.
I wonder how much sound you're losing.
How much sound are you losing?
Like the,
the,
they're not ready.
They're not technically not wav file.
Dare,
dare I think seven 20 I mean,
it's not,
it's not perfect,
but it's not bad.
It's a good sound quality.
You,
you have to have a certain standard to put it on there.
I believe.
Talked to like old time hippie dude.
So it was telling you that like vinyl record was the best.
Like that was the best quality sound.
You know,
we lost a little bit going from that to digital.
We lost something.
Laser does.
We lost it when we went to DVDs.
And laziness are better quality than DVDs.
And it's like boast is better than none.
I don't think they're better than the blueray.
I no know,
but better than DVD.
It's probably just too expensive.
Well,
Blu ray tells
laser disks to suck it.
Blu Rays,
this show,
I watched a regular movie the other day and I couldn't believe how bad it
looked.
I watched the ghost in the darkness.
Do you remember that?
It was with my old Kilmer and Michael Douglas Lion Hunting.
Val Kilmer was a handsome motherfucker.
Man.
He was handsome and chiseled and shit.
One of those,
one of those white people conquer Africa movies,
right?
Nobody in Africa could kill a lion because I ain't got to bring it to white
people from England and America to go kill a lion.
You kill a lion.
Got here,
y'all look.
Just put a bloody piece of steak.
Right
and just wait there and bang.
You go in line to the coast and the dark it.
It's the ghost in the darkness.
They were intelligent lions.
There were setting traps for them.
Intelligence.
It's kind of becomes a kind of weird,
but there,
there have been animals like that that have just strictly decided to eat people.
There was a cat tiger in India that's been recently going around on Twitter.
The Wikipedia about it is cat and India killed like 400 and something people
before they trying to kill them.
Maybe he's just trying to get even man don't apparently they just develop a
taste for flash.
It's just not normal for them because we're not normally on their food chain.
But once they find out about it,
I think we made ourselves not on the food chain.
We're on their food chain,
homey.
If we're,
if you were me,
go into the jungle like in a loin cloth.
Oh yeah.
We're,
we're,
what I mean by we're not on their food chain is not a regular part of their
diet.
So they don't recognize us as food necessarily,
but so she's not a regular part of my diet,
but I'll eat the shit out of once I'm on.
You know what I mean?
So that's five tigers.
Once they find out that they can kill people,
they become a real fucking problem.
They just go exclusively for people.
Yeah.
There was a story about,
uh,
this boat in India.
Well,
there's an area in India called the Sunderbans where over the last 100 years,
tigers have killed close to,
I think it was 300,000 people.
Something insane.
Oh yeah.
Insane number.
Insane number over the last hundred years.
It's crazy.
It's fucking crazy.
There's an area where the water,
yeah,
there's two problems with the area.
One,
the brackish water.
Apparently the tigers drink it and it makes them fucking crazy because it's
water that's like salting.
It's,
they really shouldn't be drinking and it makes it really incredibly irritated
and it makes them super hyper aggressive and they've been known to kill people.
Like for sport,
like they,
there's this one,
tiger killed these guys on a boat,
swam out to the boat,
killed the guy,
dragged him to the shore,
dropped off his body,
jumped back in the water and he did it three times and they couldn't get away
from tigers.
Can swim fast,
man.
He did it for fun.
He did it for fun until he got tired of it.
But you know,
cats are really like some of the most ruthless killers and they'll,
not only will they kill some,
but they'll fuck with it for hours before they kill it.
Like,
Oh yeah,
let me just practice on this living thing in front of my kids and slice.
It's open and this
is how you rip.
You know the hamstring on the animal when you're chasing it,
they should give lessons of murder.
Yeah,
they're creates a hell of a parent right there.
Like look,
go kill them right now.
Well we know what people don't understand is the reason why human beings have
the symbiotic relationship with cats.
It's cause or rodents.
We had the cats around cause the cats killed the right.
The mice and the rats.
They and the cats are cool.
The cats were hanging out with you and they would go jack the mice and the rats
and they would keep the rats and the mice out of your fucking food.
I mean that was where it all,
but they're there.
They're like killers,
man,
you're going to a house cat.
Everybody's a little house.
Can't you put a bird in front of it going to jump on that shit and murder it
right in front of it.
When we lived in a,
in South America,
I remember my,
my father reminds me,
he said,
listen,
they had cats out there.
The way that we have mice here.
Like they would sneak her,
they would sneak into,
into your kitchen.
They would sneak into your food supply.
Oh yeah.
And Grandma Ma did not give a shit.
She would snap it's neck like a bread stick if they got nasty and tried to,
well,
feral cats are very different than regular cats.
You know,
it's a lot of street street dogs out there.
Yeah.
Those are,
those are dangerous animals.
They can get really dangerous.
And also the Carolina diseases too.
Yeah.
Especially that toxo plasma.
I know that,
um,
that that is a disease that literally changes men's behavior and you get it from
cats.
It's the f the nuttiest fucking disease ever.
Toxo Toxo plasmosis I think it's called Toxo.
Plasmosis Gandhi's,
the actual scientific name.
I might be wrong,
but um,
it comes from cat shit.
And the way it happens is these rats get,
that's why they say crazy is catch it,
huh?
Yeah.
For Real.
Toxo asthma.
Yeah.
Plasma Toxo plaids.
Toxoplasmosis toxic.
I think that's what it's called.
And he can't,
it can't affect women.
It only affects,
no,
it effects women as well.
Okay.
Yeah.
Then they're not exactly sure,
but it's really dangerous,
especially for women if they're pregnant or when women are pregnant.
That's why they tell them never fuck with cat litter.
Don't touch a litter box because,
uh,
if they get it and they get infected,
it can,
it,
it can seriously fuck up with the development of the child while they're,
while it's in the woman's room.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a brain parasite.
Half cat,
half.
No,
no,
no.
It's not bad.
It just look,
it's,
it's not,
it's whatever this thing is,
it's in a lot of people and you can live with it.
Altered it.
It's,
it's a,
it's a parasite essentially.
It's like a brain worm literally.
Wow.
Yeah.
And what it does is it fucks with the rats and it,
it rewires the rats immune or sexual reward system and has the rat sexually
attracted the smell of cat piss.
Completely changes the rats,
the rats drive and like hijacks his whole system and makes his dick hard for cat
piss.
Literally his deck.
Okay.
So the rat is horny.
I mean it's the most ruthless shit nature has ever invented,
right?
So the rat is all horny.
He goes over to the cat is like,
has like bitch the cat,
Jack's the rat than the cat hangs around with people and then people get it from
the cat and it's been shown to make people extra aggressive.
It's been shown to make them,
uh,
act more impulsively.
Bath salt type shit.
They still think it's that bad.
But there's a disproportionate amount of motorcycle victims that tests positive
for Toxoplasma.
And um,
they,
they think it also can delay reaction time on some people too.
But there's also been a direct correlation between success for supper,
successful soccer teams and areas of infestation for Toxoplasma.
And they think it might actually make men produce more testosterone.
So it's possible that it can trick your body into acting more aggressively,
being more sexual,
producing more testosterone,
making you more impulsive.
And here's where it gets really crazy.
In England and Europe,
80% of France is infested with Toxoplasma.
80% of the French people,
people from France.
Yeah,
80% you think so?
No,
I know.
So like this is like scientific [inaudible] percent of the dude's or people
here.
Yeah,
well they are very violent people,
Joe.
I mean,
you know what I think is unfair is when I heard um,
the,
the administration Republican administration and the Bush,
the way they land Bastien and hammered the French simply because they didn't
want to go to Iraq.
And if you think about it,
dirt after World War One,
whenever we had freedom fries and that was just such a fun freedom,
fries,
whatever,
cock sucker came up with that idea.
You know,
I hope you die in a car fire.
It's the stupidest thing I've ever heard of my fucking life because freedom
fries should be what you're eating.
Fucko because without friends there would be no United States of America on
several occasion,
Francis didn't want to get bullied into something crazy.
No smart.
I tell this to us,
they became like,
cow,
you know what it is?
The Middle East was divided long time ago through a treaty called Sikes Pico
where the European nations decided that Turkey or the Ottoman empire was the
sick man of Europe.
So they cut it up.
Everyone got their little slice.
England got what's now Iraq and uh,
and Egypt,
um,
France got,
uh,
parts of North Africa,
Syria and Lebanon.
So really it's not that I'm scared to fight.
No,
that's just not my slice.
Homie.
You take care of your own problems there.
If there's an issue over here where I'm getting money and I have the remanence
of the CADAC,
this Shabbat and all this legacy of intervention,
because realistically you look at the Crusades,
they were run by Normans,
by freshmen,
by people who were maybe five,
six generations away from a man called Rolo Viking who invaded and then became,
you know,
Duke of Normandy.
So you're talking about an individual on a group of people who have been warring
and killing the beginning from the very,
I mean,
French
people,
they get away with it because you think of them in wine and poems.
But look at history,
and I'm not denigrating the French.
I'm saying y'all are wow.
Motherfuckers.
Y'All are some very,
very violent people.
You've been been involved in every sort of chaos and Melay since bone cell.
But the modern ones have evolved and they're like,
we're not interested in anymore.
We'd rather make really good wine and fuck.
They got a lot of good points.
The modern French are very cool.
They have it down there.
They're doing the right thing now fucking with the world.
You know,
the modern,
the modern French,
they don't want to be high fructose corn syrup and all that.
When I go out to Europe,
it's different.
Soda taste,
different food doesn't make you feel as just as heavy and sat and you walk out
of there like,
yeah,
we're not,
but in any way saying there's anything wrong with being French.
I met a lot of really cool French people.
I just find it fascinating when people come from really ancient cultures because
our culture is so god damn new.
You know?
And if you look at the human race and look at like in the areas where it's been
established and culture has been established for the longest to really the most
backward areas.
It's like Iraq.
Iraq is Sumir.
That's like one of the oldest known civilization where this the cradle of
civilization.
But he's,
I go,
you know,
even here we had indigenous people living here for thousands of years before and
yeah.
Oh sure.
Well,
you know what's really fascinating with a lot of people don't know is most of
North America was covered in a mile high sheet of ice up until about 10,000
years ago.
So when everybody was just balling it up in the,
in Europe and having a great time and partying all throughout the world with,
we was covered in ice except for Central America,
South America where you find sure.
Lots and lots of,
of different peoples.
Mostly they focus on Aztec Maya,
but there are so many other,
it'd be like when I came back to the Omex to Latin America,
the old Mex,
you look at their,
their,
uh,
their Shamans,
their tradition of religion,
their explanation of human society,
their use of psychotropic drugs go completely independent,
advanced civilization.
And that's what people aren't aware of.
Like when you go back like many,
many thousands of years,
what gets really interesting is it's really hard to reach other people.
So that was when people were developing very uniquely on their own.
You know,
cultures develop very uniquely,
like in their own little,
they're their own little place.
They weren't having like the constant intervention that we have from,
from all over the world.
So if you look at like what the advanced civilization of thousands of years ago
in north and South America rather,
and you look at the mind Tivoli,
like what a fucking fascinating path they,
those guys went down.
I mean,
what an amazing path these guys went down thousands and thousands of years ago
because no one was fucking with them because people,
they were like,
this is what they came up with.
What they came up with was incredible fucking stone structures that mirror the
cosmos and they were doing shit that nobody was thinking about in Europe.
No one who was thinking about the same time.
Nobody was thinking about
any of the fucking shit.
Those guys.
Right.
You know what my favorite part is when I hear people say,
Oh,
you know,
they had so many scientific advancements that as text Maya,
an Inca,
like the aliens must've helped you to do it on a one on one level.
I think that's pretty interesting.
And Ted even acknowledged for someone to say that there is extra terrestrial
life,
but at the same time,
my question is this,
those developments happened over the course of hundreds of years of thousands of
years.
We're looking at American society now that went from being in a fucking horse
and buggy 150 years ago to now being on the moon and everybody's got a cell
phone the size of a pack of tic tacs and whatnot.
So listen,
if the aliens helped anybody,
they helped people here in America,
they can help us.
You know what I mean?
Well,
I developed that over hundreds and,
and I say thousands of years of,
of work and,
and science or whatnot,
or then they've been helping everybody the whole time.
I think it's,
it's silly to assume that the aliens helped us,
but,
uh,
I don't,
I don't rule out the possibility.
I don't just because I think the human,
the human race is so ridiculous.
The whole,
the whole lot of us were so strange and bizarre that I don't,
it's just the fact that we even exist talking monkey in fact,
that we can send satellites into space.
Just the fact that we can do the nutty shit that we can do.
I would never rule out that somewhere along the line we got fucked with.
Yeah.
Someone gave us some shit or fucked with us a little bit or you know,
did some shit with some monkeys and made people,
I'm,
I'm not ruling that out man.
I'm just not rule that out.
I would say aliens before big foot,
big foot.
I'm going squatch and check him out.
Told you this,
this fucking whole area's very squats.
It was a lot of trees across the street.
I noticed that.
That's a very squatch she has some trees right down the block,
man.
I liked him going big bigfoot and they're not mad at those trees.
Those.
It cannot be hating.
You want to come with me?
No.
Come on man.
I'm gonna go camping.
Yeah,
let's go play in the woods and get raped by some dude.
We're going to go find Sasquatch.
What if,
what if we really found one came back with change?
How do you know that there's not a few thousand of them?
They're hiding in the woods.
Jupiter is 40,000 just encounter.
You know when we're going to no man,
when this fucking,
these 30,000 proposed drones are in the sky in the next couple of years,
we would already know from Google maps or Google earth,
they would see a big foot on Google map.
There's 4,000
Google maps.
Maybe they're in the cage on the ground.
They don't have like a detailed picture of every square foot of the Pacific
northwest where I wouldn't believe in Loch ness before.
I think loch ness is probably just like an eel.
It's just retarded.
They have found a relic species all over the world.
They found out on something called a cola can't in a,
in South Africa,
they thought that was dead for 60 million years.
So I can't even imagine
what's at the bottom of the ocean.
I don't even want to know.
Part of me,
part of me wants to know,
but the other half of me is like,
Yo listen,
you don't want to wait that shit up.
The cracking or whatever the fuck is down.
Well,
you know,
they found evidence that there was something like a crack and a giant octopus
type creature in the norm because the problem with,
what do they call them?
Cephalopods what does that,
what they called Maliek's the related to malls.
But what they don't have,
they don't have anything to their body.
They're,
they're just,
they're jelly.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean they don't,
there's no bones there except for their teeth.
So when they die,
that's it.
Their body just rots.
You know,
an octopus is,
it's,
it's just one piece of undulating flesh.
Completely different than our idea of like a bone structure.
And you know,
a skeletal [inaudible] didn't have any of that shit.
So
apparently they found fossils of what they think are enormous suction cups and
several of them in a row and they're pretty sure that what that is is that's
what's left of an enormous octopus that used to live in the ocean.
So the idea of the cracking,
it might've been a real thing.
It might have been an enormous octopus.
There's to be eaten.
Yeah.
Back in those times when you ran into something,
there was no such thing as a handshake back in line,
but you can imagine was an octopus that took out a boat and they actually got
that big like boat size,
like those fucking cracking pictures.
I mean they had a mega don,
which is basically,
we're talking about a great white shark that's,
you know,
65 feet long.
That shit's crazy.
And like fucking,
and their babies were like the size of great white sharks.
Now it would be a baby megalodon on a 30 foot megalodon.
Our friend bud has a tooth in his office,
a mega dawn tooth.
You pick it up and you just go,
what the fuck,
man?
It's a fossil.
So you know what a fossil is,
is the actual bone gets replaced with minerals in time.
So it's like really like a piece of stone.
It's all like a black piece of stone.
I had explained that to him.
Dudes think that this is just know it's a bone.
That's the actual tooth.
No,
no,
the tooth doesn't exist anymore and this is a fossil of the tooth.
I had explained it to him and she explained it and showed me no,
it's a real too.
It's like I paid for it.
I got to,
I got a certificate.
So it's real like I'm telling you this,
that's not exactly what a fossil is,
but anyway,
it's so big.
It's like a giant blade.
Like
it's fucking huge and you're looking at it like that was in you.
Just picture that in a mouth and the picture how big that fucking mouth and
sharks went through teeth like,
like Carson went and wives.
I mean boom,
boom,
boom.
Next one fell out.
Boom.
What a crazy animal.
The the world is invented.
I mean the word when you just toxo plasma and sharks,
the fact that those two mother fuckers exist.
You know what I'm saying?
What about a shot for a parasite that makes you wonder that as sharp with toxo
plasma
puts it didn't have tentacles,
but they had sharks instead of tenant calls the they charge to the end.
Yeah,
like the legs would be just sharp.
Oh my God.
Why not?
With talk to my classmate
that he'll do that to you.
But dude,
imagine that would be crazy at the end of it.
So much.
This is part of somebody's bad trip out there.
Someone's about to hit the Joe Rogan.
You stole that idea from me.
You know what's really crazy is that these people in South Africa have sharks,
the great whites on some sort of endanger list.
So you're not supposed to be killing him.
I'm at read that to do thinking about lifting the ban because another one killed
the fucking surfer recently.
Like apparently they're on some sort of endangered list.
One surfer died as opposed to like the hundred thousand or like 12 million
shocks that we kill every year.
Well,
that's,
that's a pretty good record,
but still I say all sharks can suck my dick and we should kill every one of
them.
I'm on team people and I like surfing and if there's anything out there that
will cut me in half when I'm surfing.
No,
not really interested in that thing.
Sticking around.
I say we send in torpedoes on submarines and just Jack every fucking shark we
find if we did that,
then all the other species that their spokes exactly right and then we'd have
more fish.
We'd see what I'm saying dog,
but we'd have less stuff.
Less of other stuff too.
Oh yeah.
You can't completely fuck with the,
we would probably give rise to some new intelligent dolphin that knows how to
make a gun.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
if you fuck the balance of power up in the ocean like that,
you know,
who knows what the result is going to be.
The fact that we do that though is a part of nature.
I mean it is our own human curiosity that it leads us to fuck with things and
remove things from the food chain and use our infinite wisdom to change like the
top,
ah,
gruffy of the earth.
But that is also a part of nature because we are all nature.
You know?
Even if people say that,
oh,
plastic is unnatural sort of,
but no,
it's natural.
The shitty humans make this.
This brings up an interesting question.
I had a conversation with a friend of mine,
Matt,
if we evolve ourselves,
right?
If we decide to genetically modify ourselves and people say that's an unnatural,
isn't that nature is nature us being,
it's all natural.
We have the ability now to be intelligent enough to map and select certain genes
and to say,
all right,
you know what?
I want to be able to take this gene that says that my organs will fail at like
80 and 90 years and I'm going to put a zero on that.
So now instead of being,
you know,
80 when I'm 80 I'm going to look 80 when I'm like 800 yeah.
I think the idea of natural is getting to be silly and I think we have to look
at it as organic and inorganic and organic still being natural but created by
people.
That's what it is.
Organic being something that occurs without any,
any intervention at all,
but it's natural that people intervene.
It's where they're curious to do.
There's a reason why this people that are in school that are studying genetic
engineering,
okay,
there's a reason why they would rather have those people figure their shit out
in 30 years and then fuck with my man and exit the food that I be out.
Look,
it's all good.
Instead of testing it out on the public now and then hiding it.
Because the funny thing is that if you're so proud of the product,
why won't you put your name on it?
Monsanto,
I see the,
the real issue is not the science.
The real issue is the commerce behind the science because the science is,
is valid.
There's,
there's,
there's certainly science to improving upon things and there might be things
that cause problems with people that we might be able to solve with science,
but the problem is then you get commerce involved and commerce looks at all
they're trying to do is figure out the best way to extract money from this and
the best way to extract money is to patent all their creations and then make a
creation that is completely unnatural and force people to buy it completely
unnatural in that you can't even use the seeds from the plant to grow.
New plants are no seeds or there are no seeds or the seeds that you have.
They don't,
they have a shelf life like they'll expire in a shorter amount of time.
There's a fascinating thing that happens when people get involved in big groups
of people that are designed to make money,
corporations,
and there's a great documentary about it called the corporation
where it's essentially show how there's a diffusion of responsibility when
there's a large group of people acting towards a goal and that the essentially
the snowflake doesn't realize it's a part of an avalanche.
It just feels like it's a snowflake.
You know?
You just feel like you're a person doing your job and meanwhile you've got
commerce mixed up somehow or another in science and progress and you've gotten
commerce involved.
So it's enforcing it's own version of these things before we know the exact
results of what could happen.
Long term ingestion has it can infect the other things in the environment.
If the parasites that are naturally preying on weed or whatever the fuck it is
that they're making,
how,
what,
what is it,
what happens to them when they're not allowed to breed,
when they're not allowed to eat,
when they're not allowed to feast on these plants that they've naturally had to
protect people from like what about,
what about that?
What,
what is,
what is the backfiring of that?
You know,
is it bark beetles?
what the fuck is it?
You know what I mean?
I think on many levels,
the
dat analysis that you brought up,
that analogy can then be used for so many other things.
You know,
it's not just about somebodies health now,
but now commerce is dictating politics.
Pilot comp,
it becomes the human race.
In other words,
companies come into existence not to find out what's the best medicine for
people,
but what's the cheapest way they can produce something that's going to offset
symptoms and then keep them coming back for more.
It's not,
there's no,
there's no money in the cure.
There's only money in a temporary solution because if you cure it then right,
and it's pure greed because there's still an incredible amount of money to be
made if they were just in the seed business and if they made seeds and then the
farmer could use that plan and grow seeds and
or get the seats from it and grow new plants and it could be a natural thing,
you know,
and then you,
you couldn't force people into suicide.
Like you've got like Indian farmers are committing suicide as a result of being
forced into using genetically modified foods and crops and being forced into an
incredible debt they can't repay.
There's something like every 30 seconds and Indian farmer commits suicide.
It's crazy.
It's fucking crazy.
I mean they've attributed not no bullshit,
more than a hundred thousand suicides in India to uh,
being a connected to a genetically modified crops.
It's fucking nuts.
They get locked into these contracts.
They can't,
they're not making as much money as they think they should be making.
Being the largest democracy in the world.
You would think that they would have the,
the ability for people to petition to say this is illegal,
but then again,
I think the problem with democracy and the problem would have in those things is
that that the commerce that you're talking about is now front and center in
terms of everything in terms of saying,
I'm going to sponsor you to be the next candidate or the next president or the
next congressman from,
but your topic,
you're fucking with life so much.
When you make something that won't even reproduce,
you're fucking with the life so much.
I just don't think you should be allowed to to that.
I think that's where it gets really tricky when you're fucking with life solely
for commerce.
Like your idea of what it would it shouldn't,
shouldn't do.
Like you're not allowing the cycle of life to continue in a natural fashion.
You're mean you,
you're,
you're making like suicide plants.
That's a,
that's a fascinating thing.
And when we let people do that,
because like,
why would you do that?
You don't only do that if you're greedy,
you know,
like you want to keep coming back for you that you're going to put on the back
making the,
the,
the plant Beto I'm people eat better when anything is just to put them in debt
and you're going to put them in a non-natural cycle.
Like why do they have to,
you know,
they can't get,
none of it can be used.
You can't like read,
take the seeds and plan and make new plants.
Really the fuck are you doing.
But then again,
that mirrors everything else.
It's like,
look,
you're getting a car,
a car that what does what that puts gas in air that that pollutes the
environment that makes us re required to be in a partnership with some of the
most uh,
off,
excuse me,
some of the most Italo attarian states that exist in,
in the world practically that we turned a blind eye to.
Now we'll focus on those that don't give us access to their natural resources,
don't have bases,
um,
in their countries.
But the ones that don't,
those that say,
okay,
well now we want to interfere.
Now we want a piece of the pie.
Now this is commerce talking.
This is no longer money.
And I think that that should be something that at some point we have to accept
as a country.
And then I think it would be tough for the soldiers to look at that saying yes.
On one hand it can be said that I'm here to be able to confront,
you know,
a state that sponsors terrorism.
It's a good line.
But at the same time,
what if all of those soldiers were told?
At the same time,
listen,
you're also here because the American economy and in order to fund this
lifestyle that we live requires you to secure a government that by our standards
has horrific human rights abuses by our standards of the same standards and
litmus test.
We used to criticize these other places,
has terrible human rights offenses,
but we need their resources.
We need them to be a part of us.
We need to support this lifestyle.
We can't because it's like if we got divorced from reality and all of us,
all of a sudden,
hey,
look,
bitch,
you can't live like you're used to live.
You're going to have to accept not going to the spy every other day.
You're only going to be able to go once a month.
Like,
no,
that's a terrible idea.
Kill 'em all.
Let's take what we have from them.
And I think that that metaphor applies not just to that,
but everything.
Now everything's about money.
It's not about what's good for humanity anymore.
Very rarely do you find someone who says,
Oh yeah,
I'm just doing this because I'm trying to find,
you know what the best thing is for people is it's no right?
How can I make this into,
you know,
a moneymaking opportunity,
even though it fucks up the entire point in the perspective of what I was trying
to do in the first place.
Right?
It just becomes about about making money regardless of the consequences of
trying to make you have leeway with entertainment to be able to do that.
Yeah.
A happy middle ground man.
You know,
just people have to just not be content.
That's really what it is.
Think about what you're doing for real.
Think about what you're doing and say is that it might be an a cunt,
like look at it,
look at it.
Realistically,
if you're being a can't stop it.
It's really that simple.
And if you got some fucking crazy ass business where you're robbing people of
their natural resources and go in there with tanks and,
and killing,
who knows how many fucking civilians and somehow or another you've passed it off
as helping someone's freedom or supporting freedom or making sure we're free.
You're a cunt.
That's a con thing.
You're,
that's crazy.
The crazy thing is it's always on the top level and it's always people who never
gone to war themselves.
They're all chicken hawk.
Always somebody who has to suffer and go exactly.
Being apart from their family and who really,
you know,
I have a lot of friends.
I have some family in the military,
you know what I mean?
Shout out to all my people's out there.
Um,
you can say that legit.
You could say shout out to all my people's out there.
It's funny,
it goes out to say it's gotta be sort of funny,
kind of shake shack.
I told my people's out there,
I want to get a shout out I shark.
I just want people to realize like it's not that when we,
when we questioned this country,
I'm not questioning the people that we're not,
we're not,
we're not angry at jaw.
We're angry at the individuals who are in charge.
They never take responsibility.
I have a friend who went to a,
went to Iraq,
he was in the army reserve for 20 years.
Okay.
And on,
he had like less than a month ago and they sent him to Iraq for a year and a
half.
They just can do that to you.
And then they send them back against sign it.
Apparently they can keep sending you back even though you like do your time in
the military and Dick Cheney sign some shit where they it so they
could just bring you back if necessary.
If you're a trained soldier,
the resources to train a new soldier,
it's too difficult apparently.
So too much money.
We can't afford that.
We've got to bring you back or whatever the fuck the excuse is.
But that's crazy.
Your,
you've made a person your slave.
So what if that person starts up a business?
What if that person out in the,
the legit freeworld is a,
you know,
got a family.
He starts up a business.
Tough Shit.
You got to go to the desert,
you go to the,
go to the desert for a year,
maybe more.
I think at some point,
um,
the individuals that were in charge of designing a war,
you know,
look at people that statistics and not real individual people because they're
not going through it.
You know,
they're more than happy to let somebody else's child do it.
But when you look at them,
it's like even the people that make this genetically modified food,
you know what I would believe a little bit more if I seen your kids drinking
that milk,
but I know that they're not,
or the individuals that'll say,
oh yeah,
you know,
I like,
I remember there was some story about a girl in the bush.
They probably would drink that milk.
See,
that's not even a problem.
I don't think these people are on a shirt and tie.
I think they're charlatans.
They're just in commerce.
I don't think they're watching their diet that clearly.
I think when people have millions and millions of dollars,
some doctor's gonna say,
you know what?
This is probably not good for you.
You probably shouldn't be doing what is like,
what?
What is,
what sort of genetically modified milk would be bad for you?
Is there something like that?
Is there a genetically modified?
There's a company,
um,
that,
that recently is gained a lot of attention called Monsanto and they've had this
big car recently.
They made DDT
recently.
Now more than ever,
I think they changed their name.
Do they change the name for a while?
They've been in the game for a while,
but we're talking about recently had so many new investigations open.
Well,
they lost a giant multibillion dollar lawsuit to farmers in Brazil,
right?
Fuck yeah.
Brazil.
Brazilian,
fuck.
Yeah,
man.
They,
they sued the shit out of beautiful women.
I win against Monsanto Jitsu and almost fucking every weight class.
I was a Brazilian champion.
There's more Brazilian champions in MMA because now you got Hennen Barao who
just won the interim bantamweight title and then you got junior dos Santos,
who is the heavyweight champion.
He had Anderson Silva,
who's the middleweight champion and you've got,
you know,
there's,
there's tough guys and every weight class from,
from Brazil,
although Joe say Aldo is the 145 pound champion,
I mean Jesus Christ,
somebody that's a lot of fucking weight classes dominated by a Brazilian.
Somebody told me you,
you recently got a black belt in Jujitsu.
Yeah,
yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
Congratulations.
I know that's a lot.
That's a lot of work.
A lot of getting choked in my neck,
my friend.
A lot of that.
I've got a back problem because of the way you see me doing like that all the
time.
It's because of my back is always fucked up from Jujitsu,
but it's so fun.
I can't help but do it more.
I had a,
I actually told you Jitsu for about three or four years when I was at digit real
and gave me a,
that's great.
Gave me a lot of real,
real life experience.
I mean,
yeah,
you struggle.
My sensei at the time,
you know,
he was a,
it was a Vietnam veteran,
a real no nonsense kind of dude.
It's always a good plot and a story of Vietnam,
no turns the hood to teach karate.
No,
he was always,
they was always in the hood.
Uh,
shout out to Sensei Stanley Thompson and he wasn't a very,
very,
very positive brother in terms of,
of how we advanced in our lessons because I remember getting life lessons from
the man,
not just how to you know someone or hit someone but when to and why to,
you know what I mean?
And the discipline required.
Like I put it on Twitter the other day.
One of the things that I always remember,
he told me,
he's like,
listen,
you know why you're wasting time with your friends running around.
There's somebody that's running and doing pushups.
When you getting high and drunk with your friends,
somebody is doing Kata.
When you are sitting there playing video games,
someone is running laps and smashing,
you know,
a,
a practice dummy.
And when this person meets you,
they're going to fucking destroy you.
And I took that like Jesus Christ.
Like either I'm going to have to commit to this or to that.
You know what I mean?
But it,
but it definitely put those things at the forefront to say,
you know what young brother,
you going to choose your life for yourself and this is what you want.
You can do it.
But at the same time,
if you're going to be involved in a situation,
just understand what the consequences of that are.
You know?
Well for me it would,
martial arts are the first time I understood the connection of what you put in
is what you get out.
I didn't understand that connection before.
I always like wanting things to happen for me,
I didn't really have like a physical thing where it was like so difficult to do
that.
I realized the only way to get good at it is just intense,
hard work and focus everything else in my life.
You know,
I was,
I was like 15 when I finally got into martial arts.
Like seriously got into it.
But everything else in my life,
you know,
whether it was,
uh,
getting into art or playing other sports there,
there was,
there was no consequences.
You know?
It's like,
so what if your picture didn't look that good?
So what if you dropped the ball,
he didn't get your ass kicked,
but once it was someone beats your ass once it was like,
oh,
this is the top of the foot.
It's either this or kill you.
It's a beat your ass or kill you.
And guess what?
If someone can beat your ass,
they can kill you.
They can kill you with their fucking hands.
If a guy gets your back and he chokes you and you tap,
you're essentially admitting that he could have killed you.
If this is a life or death struggle,
he would have put,
you would have kept the choke on.
You would have been guide person in other words.
Exactly.
And that that was reality to me.
That was like,
you got to look at,
you've got to look at your game.
You know,
you're like,
you're,
you're fighting game in your life game.
You've got to look at it hundred percent realistically,
look at it objectively,
look at it,
stand outside of it and look at it.
And I didn't have to do that until I started fighting.
I didn't have to do that.
Marty,
we definitely had,
that was one of the exercises after we had learned stuff or a certain period of
time,
we have to show what we learned by fighting a Sensei.
It wasn't like you had to fight him.
We had to fight him and he willing to take it
easy on you.
I know he will beat your ass.
Of course.
I mean that's just the way it is,
but why is he making it?
How old was this guy?
No,
I'm not talking about beat us up.
Like leave us on the floor.
Right.
He definitely,
obviously you stoop down and we were like,
maybe I was maybe like 14 like 13 or 14 and I think that it wasn't like,
like I wouldn't ever went home crippled.
I never went home.
Like not being able to see stars.
And you ever cracking you saw stars?
It was more like I definitely got the wind knocked out of me and I fell down.
Right.
Definitely he was.
It was someone who had experience teaching young children and had taught his son
from a very young age.
So it was more like it was,
it was a controlled place and it was,
it was more like in the middle of the fight we did something wrong.
We got punished for it because he said you know better,
we trained on that for weeks.
You know what I mean?
You know what to do at that particular time and now you're just being lazy
because you know it hurts to do that block that way or it hurts to get down low
and then get back up.
You know what I mean?
Well what people don't have to experience in life is that realization,
you know,
sort of this pain.
The bad thing that has happened to you only happened to you because you didn't
put in the work only happened to you because you weren't focused enough only
happen to you because you did something that you shouldn't have done and you
have no choice but to learn what the fuck that was and make sure that doesn't
happen again.
Cause that's sucks.
Life lessons.
Don't talk shit to show on the fear factor that puts you in a headlock and slap
you around like a hoe.
And I only did that to one dude.
I only did it cause I thought it was gonna hit me.
He wouldn't get away from my face.
I pushed him away from me twice and I was like,
if this guy comes in again,
I'm just going to manhandle them.
I mean,
you know,
some people are really brave when it comes to barking on a woman,
but when they deal with a man,
it's a whole nother story.
Well I was,
you know,
trying to make sure that it wasn't sued too.
Like I didn't want to do anything.
I knew there was nine cameras on me.
It was like when I had the back of his head,
I'm wanting to make sure that nothing I did,
I was going to get me in trouble now because I mean in that position you could
have done so many other things that would have just left them angry too.
Because I knew this guy had done some shit before on other shows,
like attack.
Some counselor on one show and through his wife on the ground on another show.
I knew it was all he was.
It was crazy.
So I say this much.
When I was at,
when I was a young man,
my father told me,
he said,
listen,
the man who hits his woman is a coward.
Like my father was a very strong man.
He said,
listen,
because he's taken out all the problems on the rest of the world that people are
giving him.
You know what I mean?
For all of this and taking it out on the person that's supposed to support him.
Instead of him doing that,
unless asked my father,
I said,
what if it's talking about the Sean Connery?
What if it's the woman that's given him all the problems?
And I said,
Yo,
at that point he's just get up and leave.
That's the worst thing you could do to a woman that's obsessed with trying to
ruin your life.
You get up and walk out,
never answer a phone call and never,
you know what I mean?
Well,
you just kind of never let it get down that road.
When you see it getting down that
road to being so crazy,
you might hit each other.
You've got to get out.
Either change,
both of you come to some mutual agreement or get out.
People don't,
you know,
they get in these crazy patterns in relationships.
That's a big part of the fucking problem.
They get used to being in a situation where the yell and scream at each other
and then when they go into the next relationship,
totally seems normal.
They grew up like that.
Did you,
I grew up like that.
Did you grow up like that?
I grew up with,
uh,
both of my parents together.
I'm not saying that everything was perfect,
but I put it this way.
My father was a very,
very strict and very,
very like tough man on us,
but I've never seen my dad hit my mother and I've never seen my father drunk in
my life ever.
Like my dad was,
he taught in the military academy.
He was like really,
really tough on us when we were kids.
But at the same time I can say that I am everything I am because you know
somebody loved me because he took the time to say,
hey,
you know what I'm going to take?
My son was 12 to the Amazon jungle with me.
Oh,
you're scared of roaches.
Well,
what happens when they're all flying to fuck around you now deal with it.
You know what I mean?
Like deal with the reality of fucking life.
Dude,
this is life.
You know,
you think you're,
you think you're poor because we live in Harlem,
right?
Let's go to the jungle.
Let's take you to some little real fucked up area and [inaudible] so you can see
people that eat like cardboard smashed in with like dog meat and that's their
lunch.
And I know it's cardboard.
You know it's cardboard Joe.
They know it's cardboard too,
but there's still going to eat it because they're fucking starving.
He's like,
so I think my,
my pops really just kind of beat the lessons of life and to me,
you know what I mean?
That's good man.
That's good to have.
That's a lot of times kids will resent the father like that,
that puts so much effort and work into it.
But it's tough for dad too.
You gotta know when to let that fucking kid beat himself.
Oh,
I know,
man.
It's hard.
Hard to raise children.
I mean,
I,
I put it this way,
uh,
you know,
for a long time me and my father had a very,
very negative relationship because of all the crazy stuff I was doing.
And then when I got older,
I started to realize that a lot of the things that he was trying to do with
things that were,
were very effective.
Like for one time he kicked me out real,
real,
real shit.
I hardly ever talk about this,
but fucking we're here.
Um,
and he was basically like,
no,
look,
I love you.
You know,
you,
you're my firstborn son.
But you know,
you got drugs in his house,
you know,
there's something else in there.
You know what I mean?
And you're in danger in the family.
I'm not going to let you endanger your mother and your younger sister by running
around him being crazy.
So you know what you can do,
you can get your stuff and you can get the fuck out and real shit.
I left.
How old were you?
Like 1615 and a half to do that.
When you have a 15 and 16 year old is doing that,
you really don't have any options.
And for a long time,
John,
I was kind of resentful until I sat back and I said,
damn,
as cliche as that sounds,
that really must have hurt him more than it hurt me cause I,
I was like,
fuck you.
And I left and I walked out.
But for him it must've been like,
damn,
are you that ignorant or you that foolish at that age?
Which is why I always believe like when I see people
that are in no circumstances,
there was,
this was even before I went to prison.
This was before I had any real league,
which drives and forth for assault.
But I had multiple assault charges.
I just used to fight a lot when I was a kid.
I thought that would solve everything.
You know,
I was the one of those idiots that was willing to fight to the death against
someone who's not my enemy.
And the street is full of those fools right now.
This is the life note.
It's not life or dead homie.
You're going that way and someone's in your way.
You can go around them and it'll be a lot less time.
I'm amazed sometimes at how lippy people get for no reason,
no reason.
People get crazy like they're ready to go.
It's almost like they're bluffing,
but if you call them on their bluff,
they'll go,
you know,
most of the time people are bluffing,
but they're still there.
They're putting themselves on,
on,
you know,
unfucking a yellow light.
They're putting themselves in a bad situation.
But I mean at the same time,
Joe,
I not,
and this is not to excuse my actions and in any way,
shape or form,
I take responsibility for them.
But New York was a very different city.
Like if you grew up in New York in the,
in the late eighties early nineties you had to have some kind of physical
confrontation or somebody who's going to treat you like a victim.
Like if somebody wanted your hat,
it was like,
no homie,
you can't have this hat because you ain't pay for it.
Oh,
well give it,
and that's where we start.
I lived in Jamaica plain for a little over a year and Jamaica plain is the first
place we moved to Boston and it was a pretty poor and real mixed area and
Goddamn I how to avoid everybody on my block or I would get my ass kicked.
Everybody wanted to fight all the time.
All the time.
Kids were always trying to pick fights that always talk shit to you and they're
like,
look,
I'm going home.
Leave me alone.
And like they're just constantly talking shit with you.
Constantly.
Fucking when you're big groups of kids,
small groups of kids,
and when kids are alone,
they're loose like that,
especially in poor neighborhoods.
So they grow up.
Most of the times they're growing up with your fucking parents or they're not
having the best time.
That's why they were in a,
in a poor neighborhood.
So it's probably violence at home or screaming and home or chaos at home and
then these kids are just fucking loose out on the street.
It was,
uh,
that was like really,
really inspired me to get into martial arts.
I was like,
fuck this man.
This is too dangerous.
And for where I'm going,
some of them wants a fight.
I don't know how to fucking fight.
Like this is crazy.
When you got the martial arts,
then you could just call them out.
You had a big group look rather than not men,
you know the martial arts maybe just walk lap.
No,
no,
but I mean when you're backed into that corner now go find fine.
I'm saying when you're in that plate,
in that situation,
and there's like eight people talking reckless,
it'd be like,
listen,
if you're a real man,
why don't we just shoot the five right now?
You shouldn't shoot the five.
What does a,
he's just going one on one,
shoot.
The five,
shoot the fire,
never heard of that.
Shoot the five fingers or we get the fair one.
That's what they call it.
The fair fair one.
The fat one.
I'll be here in the west coast.
It's catches fade homie.
You know what I mean?
But out there on the east coast,
let's shoot the fan one because it's just me and you.
While we have a space and opportunity,
I'm amazed at how many dudes are willing to fight that actually don't know how
to fight.
It's amazing.
When I watched him and I'm like,
that's
incredible.
You don't even know anything and you're out there scrapping like doing the
windmill out there.
They're doing the windmill,
the throwing ridiculous kicks in.
They have no training at all and you're like,
oh my God,
this is hilarious.
This is like,
yeah,
this is a crazy idea.
You're willing to do something that's really fucking dangerous and risky and
you're not good at it at all,
at all,
at all.
I watched a fight go down once in front of the comedy store and it was the Nadia
Shit I ever saw in my life.
I saw a guy completely lose his ability to figure out what he was doing.
Like he was so freaked out that he was in a fight with this guy.
He was a white guy,
black guy,
and the white guy is literally frozen in fear and flailing his arms like this.
I mean he had just was going like this,
like waiting to get hit and a fucking bus moved in front of me and then as the
bus move by,
the dude was laid out,
stiff leg and even again unconscious and the black dudes were already running
happy birthday.
Mitzi.
Yeah.
Happy Birthday.
Mitzi.
Is it really her birthday?
How old is she?
Well,
don't be on say a lady doesn't tell.
We're giving shout outs to Mitzi shore to Mitzi.
Shout to Mitzi.
Shout to my people's up a Neil [inaudible] watching from the east coast snot a
product and her brother.
You know what I mean?
I want to send a shout out to the whole rep alarms the whole squad.
This that's watching right now.
Everybody,
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't go fight in the street.
Even if you do know what you're doing.
It's the last option.
People got to learn how to chill,
right?
That's the hard part,
How the fuck does this world evolve?
If we're still involved in all the wars and all the craziness and all that,
how the fuck do we get past this?
The more I look at the life that we see on TV every day and the tragedies that
we see in the news and the horrific things that are going on all over the world,
the more I got,
there's gotta be a way that collectively we can figure out how to stop.
Most of the shit.
Most of this shit that I'm looking at is people doing shit to other people and
we collectively stop that.
It's almost like because we're not dealing with Ufo woes or asteroids or
anything nutty outside of the earth,
all of our conflicts are being caused by people doing country shit to other
people.
Like literally the whole world's problem is the whole world.
The people in the world's problem is the people.
It's,
it's,
it seems like that should be the easiest thing to solve.
That should be the easiest thing to figure out.
How to get past.
It's like we're in like the crazy person that never learned from their crazy
actions.
It just keeps doing the same stupid shit over and over and over.
Crazy person that doesn't realize they're crazy.
Like most of you.
Crazy people don't seem to get,
I think what we're talking about here is,
is really the evolution and the d evolution of mankind because we have,
you know,
we're so close,
we haven't the ability to be on other planets almost.
I mean we have the ability to create these lasers,
these incredible communication devices,
these incredible travel for gene,
but we have not cured greed.
We haven't cured racism.
We haven't cured,
you know what I mean?
Jealousy,
anger,
hatred were ruled by these things and people that can control them and know how
those function within the human mind have more of an ability to control.
Well,
it's when things get created,
say something spectacular or something destructive.
The people that are creating that thing,
then that technology gets put into the hands of people that did not create it.
They just have it now.
And that is always a problem when someone wields something of incredible power
and they didn't even create it.
You know,
you just got it from,
so do you understand the whole process behind it?
What if you are the type of person that can create that?
Are you the type of person that would be willing to unleash it on people?
I think you'd be more willing to unleash it if you bought it.
You know,
if you got it from somebody else.
It's just we have the ability to do shit that we don't have the moral evolution
to cope with.
We have the ability to wipe out like giant sections of the world in like real
quick blasts and we somehow or another feel like,
you know,
because we do it a little bit more precisely,
like in Iraq,
like that's a little bit more precisely.
You send actual troops in there instead of just dusting the whole area.
It's still a massive amount of casualties and they love to use the same result.
The,
the,
the word,
that catchphrase,
collateral damage,
you know,
which I think is one of the worst excuses for murder in the world.
It's crazy.
It's crazy and the sad part,
the sad part is the people who catch the blame are always the people on the
bottom.
The enlisted men,
like even in Abu Ghraib.
When I saw that,
I was like,
oh,
okay,
watch.
All the soldiers are going to get some kind of shit to them,
but the people,
the commanders,
the,
the officer's in charge.
The people who decided the policy at Dod,
the individuals who were at the,
the administration who said,
yeah,
this is fine.
Do what you need to do to get this.
Those people that gave free range,
they always escape.
They always seem to have their little exit in the back door while the
individuals who actually did it and yet bear no responsibility for being told to
do it or being told,
this is what we're going to do,
or this is the
in the zone.
What happened at noble grape?
I thought it was just a soldier's deciding to be fuckheads and take pictures
with bodies.
Do you know?
I'm not going to say,
I'm not going to say that,
that,
that that isn't part of what happened,
but I believe in all of these situations that there was some kind of culture
within the society that says,
you know what?
If you get caught doing this,
you're going to do the time for this.
As opposed to whoever is on the top for it.
It's always benefits of being here.
So always crazy when a stranger is your enemy.
Okay?
That doesn't make any sense.
If a stranger is your enemy,
one of two,
someone's doing something fucked up and see the you were,
it's him.
You've got to figure out who it is and if you're in his town and you're carrying
a gun,
then it's you.
You're not supposed to be there.
Like you just said,
the only way you can get for al Qaeda country that don't have this,
it's just fucking crazy.
The only way you would have a stranger that's your enemy is if we were in a
place where he couldn't communicate well,
that's,
we're not in that place anymore where we're in a totally different world.
This isn't the world of 10,000 years ago when we show up in a fucking wooden
boat,
he hit the beach and this dude shooting arrows at us,
we've got to kick some ass.
It's not,
it's,
this is,
this is a totally different world we're living in now.
It doesn't make any sense,
but has humanity and evolve natural.
In other words,
if we took somebody from now and supplanted them into that era,
would they simply act the same?
Or if we took somebody from that era and put them in in now,
wouldn't have results simply be the same?
Um,
I don't know.
I think I would like to think that we've evolved a little bit or a more,
a larger percentage of us have evolved a little bit because of the Internet,
because of people's abilities to express themselves in a way that,
you know,
Monsanto didn't really have to hear from the regular people in the 1960s when
they were making agent orange.
They didn't have to,
he,
you know,
there was a protest of the news.
And if there's not a bunch of people carrying signs,
you're not getting anything from the people.
You know what I mean?
It's not like today when people on Twitter would go fucking crazy and,
and any,
any,
uh,
big story that happens and he'd been corruption store and a big and a boy cat.
She has serious consequences.
And then it was going to say,
contact this person and you're going to have economic consequences by the end of
the day.
Which by the way,
is all that they listened to.
Well,
by the way,
today,
chick filet a Roseanne Barr went off on Chick-Filet because the governor of
Massachusetts,
God bless his soul,
uh,
was talking about how chick filet is not welcome in a,
in,
in Boston because Chick-Filet has this pro.
They some,
it was something to do with their a idea.
They have a very religious company apparently.
And uh,
it has something to do with their ideas and check the light.
Yeah.
They,
they won't even serve on Sunday.
They're closed and it's closed every Sunday.
They lose millions of dollars every year because of that.
But that's just the way it is.
If you fucking sandwiches a delicious,
you know,
I made the guy may be naughty with Jesus,
but he makes a hell of a fucking chicken sandwich,
but apparently bought a good,
or he bought a good recipe once upon could be.
But yeah,
I don't know what it is,
but whatever it was,
whatever the statements from chick filet were addressed by the mayor of Boston,
I think it was right.
It was the mayor of Boston and the governor of Massachusetts.
I didn't know that either one,
whatever,
whoever the,
I don't know.
I haven't lived in a long time.
I don't know who's running shit,
but whoever's running shit,
uh,
essentially said that they weren't welcome.
You know,
they,
they don't,
uh,
observe same sex marriages.
I don't know what the fuck else it was.
You know,
whatever statements.
It was kind of funny because people should be allowed to think whenever the fuck
they want to think.
And who cares?
Just the chicken sandwich place,
you know,
as long as they're not actively victimizing anybody,
they can have their nutty beliefs.
You know?
I think you're allowed to have your nutty beliefs.
Even if you're not,
he believes,
don't jive with mine.
You're allowed.
You're allowed to have,
you know,
as
long as they're not affecting her,
as long as they're not hurting people.
What the,
but then again,
maybe chick filet is,
is part of this big Super Pac donors that say we're going to give money to try
effect this legislation.
Then it becomes different than your opinion is not your opinion.
Then you're starting to use your money that you get from all of the things that
you have to bolster this opinion and make people believe that your opinion is a
fact rather than just your fucking opinion gets tricky.
Right.
Then we're going to decide.
It gets tricky when your profit off distributing your your opinion,
you know,
and getting people to go along with it just,
well Joe,
this is kind of what you and me do.
We profit by distributing our opinion on and stuff.
Sure,
but we don't have any influence on,
on,
you know,
um,
the ability to control countries were very simple.
Come,
come to a comedy show influence.
No,
very different.
Very different.
They're suing Batman.
Yeah.
Warner brothers.
The other people involved in the,
because you know,
I don't want to say anything bad about those poor fucking people,
but someone apparently had the idea that they can make some money.
It looks like they're suing them for um,
promoting violence,
which is ridiculous because this was the third movie in a Batman Trilogy.
You mean you knew exactly what it is.
The fucking whole movie is about a crime fighter.
And they were saying also that because of the movie they,
the guy came in and the costume,
they thought he was a part of the movie and it was,
you know,
they wasn't that more than theaters responsibility cause they was supposed to
close that and they knows man who the fuck knows like somebody who wants to do a
huge investigation.
But the sad thing is now,
you know,
people want to know everything.
It's just,
I see the difference in between the way people are treated and I think it's kind
of hard to ignore and you know,
and there's no specific cause right now that they have of his actions.
However,
I know what it would be if he had been like,
you know,
he had like a Muslim last name.
It'd be like automatically he must be a terrorist and this is,
he must,
he killed military personnel.
It must be attack if he,
if he was,
he's actually scarier.
He's scary than someone that's a part of some sort of a religious ideology.
Latino,
they'd be like,
college,
these student,
he's an illegal immigrant.
Get 'em out of here or a black guy.
He's a gang member.
Rather than just being like,
Hey,
and I saw that circulating on the Internet and I wonder how real that could
potentially be even to the fact of him being alive.
If he was of,
you know,
of complexion that can't make the connection.
Would he be walking in?
I mean,
would they want to take him alive when they just be like,
look,
just pop him.
We don't need somebody like this run through the media.
Just get rid of.
I think when you get to a situation like that,
there's too many cameras on you.
You know the reason why they didn't kill that guy where they might have killed
that guy back in the day was out.
There's too many people with cameras on you and you can get sued for that.
You know,
you can get sued if somebody has a cell phone camera.
You don't know about it.
You can't just murder the guy right there.
You're fucked.
Because if you do that,
they'll put you in jail for murder unless you're a cop and you're in the bay
area because he shot that kid.
Well,
he fucked camp one camp.
He's an idiot.
He thought that was his taser.
That's stupid.
Fuck you really think that that's true.
I don't know.
But it,
Taser is a fucking device with a trigger.
And if you're an idiot,
if you're a fucking idiot and you're freaking out because you're in the middle
of a physical confrontation with someone and you accidentally pull your gun and
said,
have your Taser.
I mean,
I can't think that he thought it would be okay to shoot that guy like that.
That doesn't even make any sense.
It seemed more like a fucking moron move cause the guy was already lying down on
the ground.
He was resisting.
You wouldn't shoot them.
What?
You already have them down in the ground.
Well,
I mean,
I mean he was trying to do people do things like that all the time.
They don't think they're going to have consequences.
Well,
if that's the case,
he's a psychopath because it didn't make any sense that he shot him.
Well,
I mean,
made sense though.
The dye his hair like the,
like the,
like the Nigga who killed,
uh,
do you mean the new,
okay,
we're talking about two separate things.
No,
no,
no.
He did his head to the new guy.
The cop dyed his hair.
The cop that shot that kid in the subway.
Yeah.
He dyed his hair and he,
he uh,
he went to like,
uh,
they caught him somewhere else.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
You mean the cop fled?
Yeah,
he bounced for a little while.
Oh,
I didn't know God was gone.
Look it up.
Look it up online.
I believe you.
I didn't know that.
Well,
maybe it's,
well maybe he just thought he was going to jail for life.
It just fucked up and he panicked.
Who knows?
But he got a slap on the wrist and I always joke about it.
I joke about it along the skin.
Nothing.
Hardly anything.
Probably.
I think it probably was a mistake.
I don't know.
But it's a terrible mistake.
The Guy,
the kid ask a grant.
I've mean,
I can't even imagine how many more people ended up like him within that era
where there was,
like you said,
no cameras when he was,
no,
no.
One day.
You know how many people applied victim of that?
Yeah,
I know a lot of cops,
man.
They see the,
one of the problems is you're a cop.
You see a lot of shit,
see a lot of shit all the time and you lose your patients,
you lose,
you lose your patients and you,
you know,
you,
you become more attuned to the kinds of the world then you would like to be and
you don't want to hear any fucking bullshit anymore.
So very,
very fucking tricky job.
My,
your humanity.
My question is this,
now I'm seeing the worst than p being did.
I know that there are people out there who really do risk their lives.
Like if someone's house is getting robbed or well,
how about this guy fucking this guy in Denver,
man,
they had it.
Someone had to go in there and stop him.
You know,
this isn't,
this isn't something that you,
you know,
the community could just rally together.
No one had guns.
But my question is the police that break the law [inaudible] should they be held
more accountable because they know the law that much better?
Like in other words,
if had killed somebody or should you get time to minimize?
For example,
there's a case in in New York where a guy,
he got like a a year of probation or something or was it a year in one year in
jail because he killed a guy while he was drunk driving and he's,
he's his family is apparently connected with the NYP ds.
This is my question though.
If if you're a cop,
shouldn't you be held accountable to the law even more so because you knew it
was wrong to be drunk and driving.
You arrested probably a hundred
times to doing the same thing.
Thank that it's ever been shown that to put people in a situation where it's
whatever they're doing that's wrong has more of a consequence.
I don't think that's ever been shown to him.
It have any effect on their actions.
I think people do shit cause they think they're going to get away with it.
They don't do shit because they measure the consequence and go,
all right,
I might do a year in jail.
Fuck it,
let's ride.
They don't do it like that there.
It's,
it's more of an impulsive sort of a thing when,
when people make
mistakes,
but if people know,
listen,
there's no way that I'm really going to catch it that much heat for this because
who the fuck is,
right?
If I'm drunk and somebody pulls me over and we both play for the same team,
you're going to bring me in.
You know what's going to happen to you after that?
Really crazy is how many cops turned out to be corrupt back in the days before
the Internet.
I mean,
I think it's very difficult to be corrupt today,
but I think,
uh,
back in the day it was probably pretty fun
and easy.
I'm just saying,
I think it's slightly less difficult to be corrupt.
I mean,
I think you can if,
if there's money in it for you,
you know,
and I think there's levels of corruption,
there's harmful levels,
and then there's simple stuff like,
you know what?
I'll fix it.
Tickets for you.
You know,
we're good friends.
That's corruption.
Whether or not it's,
it's bad in people's kids are dying.
Someone shouldn't have the ability to do that.
They say,
you know what,
you're connected with me.
I'll give you the card when you have a problem,
you call me and I take care of it.
I know people that benefit from that.
I know people that had been in situations where they may not be 100% right and
they have a specific card or something like that,
and I'm not denigrating this thing.
I'm just saying that at some point,
you know,
are you more responsible for your corruption because you know the law 10 times
better and you're enforcing it and forcing it.
In other words,
if you get caught for murder and and then you're off all of a sudden in five
years,
that's only because you knew the law better and then you still broke it.
Well,
we was selling drugs.
Like I said,
I don't think that you can,
you make people more responsive when you're going to change anything.
You might make people feel better because you're punishing them more,
but I don't think you're necessarily going to change behavior by offering a
bigger consequence.
I think the only way to change behaviors to change thinking,
and what I try to tell people is,
and it sounds ridiculous,
but this is something that came to me on a boat once,
is that you got to treat everybody as if it's you live in another life.
We could all do that.
If we could all picture ev,
any person,
regardless of what the fuck they're going through in your life,
think about what it would be like to live that person's life from birth to death
with their situation,
their economic situation,
their biological situation there,
their life experiences.
Would you be any different than that person?
If you are that man,
if you were that woman,
would you be any different?
Are you them?
You know,
if that person was born you,
would they be you?
And Are we all the same like that?
And is that what life really is all about is figuring out that each one of us is
exactly the same.
We're just living through a different biological circumstance.
And the more you can treat everyone you meet,
like there,
you living another life,
the happier you'll be.
And that's the only way we're ever going to sort this thing out is everyone has
to do things based on that ideal everyone had,
whether it's business or personal shit.
Whatever you do,
you always have to think that this person that you're dealing with is you living
another life and you can't let them boss you around.
Can't let them talk shit to you.
Can't let them fuck up your life.
You know you do your best to keep them on track,
but your ethic and your resolve and your,
your intent should always be to treat them as if it was you living a whole
nother last year.
Somebody who hates yourself and then that's just what you gotta get your shit
together,
son.
That's a whole nother fucking people up like I fucking agent.
Well,
they just closed down all these medical marijuana dispensaries in California,
uh,
or they just sent a letter in Los Angeles.
Los Angeles has decided to step in in their infinite wisdom and shutdown the
only businesses that are regularly making money.
All of Los Angeles so stupid.
It's so fucking dummies.
The first American Fletcher is made of hemp.
Yeah.
I'm one real shit.
When the drafts of the declaration of Independence was written on hand,
but mean who cares about all that stuff?
The idea of that.
You know why?
Because I think it takes the story back and it shows us,
listen,
people made their clothes out of this.
People did everything look right,
but that's not even the psychoactive stuff.
We live in a culture now where the smoke that causes cancer is legal and the
smoke that cures cancer is illegal.
It doesn't necessarily cure cancer,
but it certainly reduces what I'm just saying,
that by the way,
Tommy Chong,
for all the people that listen to the podcast,
Tommy Chong is 99% cancer free now.
She just started these,
God bless has been doing this,
a hemp oil stuff and uh,
it's a,
there's,
Rick Simpson is the guy who invented this hemp oil apparently is just really
potent form of under the oil from cannabis and it puts you on the fucking moon
and in the process of shrinks tumors.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
congratulations to our friend Tommy Chong.
That's a,
that's awesome news.
Congratulations.
Amazing that this guy did it with no chemotherapy.
He did it with holistic medicine,
meaning vitamins and food and not meaning like anything crazy like sucking on
crystals,
make it all noises,
holistic meaning treating the body as a whole,
giving it nutrients,
giving you a cheeky does what I do every morning as a,
a Kale shake,
you know,
and uh,
which is a lot of people have been doing this and if you're down for health and
vitality,
man,
there's very few things in life better than a really fucking thick,
heavy nutrient dense vegetable shake in the morning.
And it does not taste good.
I'm not going to fucking lie to you.
I chew this shit down every day and every day I think about finding a way to
pussy out of this,
like on Mantras,
have some bacon and eggs.
Fuck this,
but I don't.
I drink this God damn awful concoction.
I was feeling like a little bit sick when I came back from Canada the other day
and a lot of traveling shit.
I drank the shit one day.
By the end of the day I felt great.
That's never happened.
Every time I get a cold,
by the end of the day,
I'm ready to go to sleep.
I'm fighting this off.
I got to take a hot bath the next day.
You know,
it takes like a day to fight off a cold.
By the end of the day it was done
because I'm eating nutrient dense shit bitches.
Okay?
I go,
I go crazy with it.
My latest thing.
I add coconut oil to it because Rob Wolf,
who will be on tomorrow,
the author of the Paleo Diet said that in order for you to get maximum
absorption of the vitamins from plants,
you should have them with some fat and the way the human body works,
you should have a little bit of fat.
So I started adding coconut oil to that shit.
Son and coconut oil has been known to help people who have Alzheimer's disease.
There's a some sort of a connection between Alzheimer's disease and diabetes
that it's almost like a,
a sort of a cousin of diabetes for the brain or something like that and they're,
they're having positive results.
Giving a Alzheimer's patients coconut oil.
Coconut is a wonderful fucking plant.
What an amazing resource coconuts are.
It tastes delicious.
You can eat the meat of it,
you drink it,
there's oil in it,
it's great for you.
This fucking there.
You can't think anything better for rehydrating and coconut milk.
The water from coconuts is the shit too.
Oh,
butters is there.
Coconut butter.
Coconut butter is good.
And my favorite candy bar of all time is a almond joy because it has coconut
almond joy.
Is the almonds alone.
Good enough?
Nope.
Need some coconuts back that shit up.
You know,
it's what it is.
Mars.
Mars is even better than I have preferred Maras over Almond Joy.
But it's tough to just find Mars.
Damn.
You don't even,
I found out last night,
Joe,
you're going to freak out about this thing about,
I won't down the street,
maybe a mile that way.
And here's a Roscoe chicken and biscuits or whatever.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
you didn't know that.
No Dude,
they opened one in [inaudible] boy.
Yeah,
go.
Whenever we do rock the bells were going to do a tour and I'm an August,
I'm gonna be back here on the west coast and I got a big show,
um,
in San Bernardino and then I have one on a San Diego,
Ventura,
San Luis Obispo,
Fresno and on that.
But whenever all the dudes come in,
that's the first thing.
Roscoe's tutor Roscoe's man,
it's tough to beat that combination.
They nailed it,
man.
And that chicken is the best fucking fried chicken you will ever have.
It's not just,
it's fried,
just fried chicken or just waffles.
The waffles are perfect.
They're goddamn American waffles.
Okay,
Ladies and gentlemen,
not this Belgium bullshit.
It's big fat,
fluffy fucking loaves of bread that you're soaking up the syrup with.
No,
it's a Goddamn flat waffle and American waffle with some bad ass fried chicken.
You can't fuck with Roscoe's are too good.
I like it.
Especially with hot sauce.
That chicken with hot sauce.
I always say,
listen,
if if they opened one in New York,
they would make a killing,
killing it would crush it.
They would crush it.
There would be lines out the door every day.
Same with in and out,
man.
If in and out got to New York,
you know there's some people on the west coast that have figured some shit out.
Chicken and waffles and in and out burger
to then end and the cannabis dispensaries to hit
well.
Yeah,
but meanwhile they're these concert clothes and I'm here.
It's so crazy.
It's like in mid mom,
if he gets an office,
a court for this or that,
just they started the,
I don't know,
they just,
they made a statement today.
They ruled off somebodies got a,
so this is a city council ruled,
right?
Is that what it was?
But when I don't understand is how,
how they can just do that because there's a lot of these people,
our families and this is their family business now and they've invested so much
time and money and they,
they've,
they were allowed doing it because they have power and that they didn't earn.
They don't deserve it.
They're dumb cunts.
That's why they're doing it.
They're idiots.
The idea that it's hurting anybody's preposterous.
So the idea that you're protecting people from anything is ridiculous.
What are you doing?
What are you doing that's good for the common welfare?
It's good for the community.
It's what you're doing is absolutely a logical and based on a false pretense.
And that is that there's something wrong with taking cannabis.
There's nothing wrong with it.
There's nothing wrong with it health wise.
And there's no one's getting victimized by it is no addictive properties to it.
I don't give a fuck what doctor drew says,
marijuana is not physically addictive.
And if you get addicted to pot,
you could get addicted to any who said that?
Doctor drill.
You could get addicted to beaten off.
You can get it playing with your eyelids.
There's people that are addicted to plucking hairs out of their arms.
Okay.
That doesn't mean that plucking Harris out of your arms should be illegal.
What is the fucking stupid as people are broken bitches.
This is the other thing.
Yeah.
I,
I can't drive a car when I'm drunk.
I wouldn't try.
Um,
but I could definitely drive very safely when you're high.
If I'm bleeding,
yeah,
there's,
there's certain things you can do.
You know what I mean?
And there are certain things you just cannot,
well,
I don't like to drive high,
but I could do it if I had to.
I do Jujitsu high all day.
I do it all the time.
It's no problem.
I kickbox hi.
It's like,
it feels natural to me.
It doesn't bother me.
I don't like learning new techniques when I'm high.
I like training.
I like what if rolling or I'm hitting the mitts or something like that.
I liked doing that when I'm high,
but if I was like someone,
someone's trying to teach me some new way to throw a kick or someone that I
wouldn't want to do with it,
you know?
Then I want to have all my faculties.
I don't want to be distracted.
But when you know what you're there to do,
you could,
you get high,
you just get into that groove.
There's no physical repercussions of it.
I'd have no,
and again,
slowing and my reflexes are moving.
Just to clarify,
I'm not advising that people get high and I'm advising the people get high and
do Jujitsu.
I'm not advising people get get high and drive,
but if you want to get high and do Jujitsu or do something that I swear to God
it knocks my Jujitsu up a notch.
Yeah,
I believe so.
You know,
I think even with the delay,
there's no delayed reaction time.
That's what silly.
You know,
people,
first of all,
people are getting that indigo.
We'd learned that into Kuwait is all over
the east coast.
Very hard for you guys to get sativa because you guys aren't,
you aren't a illegal environment in California.
It's legal.
So they figured out a way to grow the more psychoactively potent strains of uh,
uh,
of Sativa,
like a train wreck and you know,
there's a green crack and it's the one called the sage that were smoking right
now these things are fucking Carl Sagan,
weed man,
cosmos type Shit.
This is not the kind of weed that makes you like sink into the couch and the
kind of way that you get on the,
on the east coast.
We don't all get that.
We don't all get bad.
It's not bad weed,
bro.
I mean,
not saying I like west coast.
We'd,
I did.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not even saying that west coast we'd,
there's a lot of great west coast.
Endeca when I was saying is you don't get too much sativa.
Then in the end it goes great.
It's hard to get.
It's harder to get and it's hard to know for sure that the guy you're selling it
you're selling to is legit.
Whereas I can go to a dispensary,
you know,
and just walk into a place and they have the exact strength still Ken,
where I live,
dude,
I don't live in La.
It takes off.
It takes,
it takes the violence side of it.
We're taking the violence out of the drug trade by doing that,
taking the creepy people out.
We're taking,
we're putting tax on something.
You're making money.
It's an American pastime.
Half the founding fathers were high.
They were probably high when they were writing the declaration of independence
and the constitution.
Yeah.
I hope they weren't there.
Would,
it would have been a better piece of literature as well.
That's probably why it's so good.
They were high as fuck when they were high and shit like,
Yo,
what should we do?
What should we do?
And then like the assholes among them.
We're like,
hey,
let's put in,
uh,
all men should be free and then let's just have slavery instead like fucking
hell.
It's amazing that we haven't like wroten written a new one.
Like how about we get together and decide like as a fucking race,
what's the best thing we could do for the race and we should have all of our
guidelines and everything agreed upon by you know,
the intelligent people of the world.
We should have it not based on who's in power and who's in control and can they
manipulate that and make money.
It should really,
all of our rules are how society's done should be for the betterment of
improving our society.
But it's not.
It's not because there's constant power.
They're not sacrificing themselves and their own pleasure and their own profit.
In order to help you and aid you got to look at it as if everybody is,
you live in another life or even teach them to do that or even in terms of of
getting a profit nowadays.
What is that?
It's a digital salary.
It's a bunch of numbers in the computer or I need your sack of gold.
Fucking deers balls.
Dear ball sack with gold coins in it.
You mother fucker.
I told them,
cause when I was coming here I was like,
Yo man,
I hope that this mother fucker don't do nothing crazy.
What they'll pull out.
No Elk,
penis,
no fucking crazy fear factor shit.
Shit.
These people always say that you got any bugs on you?
Hey Martin,
what do you think?
Killed Biggie.
Oh man,
that's crazy out there.
And you Brian.
All right.
Ah,
ask everyone are up in east coast,
west coast.
No,
no.
You know what's funny?
I,
I have a lot,
a lot of,
uh,
support on the east coast because that's where I'm from.
But this is probably one of the places in like in la where I could do a bigger
show than I could in New York.
I think it's just because New York is like 10 cities put together and La is like
20 cities.
But it's also,
they probably appreciate you more when you're not at all the time.
You know,
it's just natural.
if you're,
you're used to doing shows in New York,
everybody's like,
oh,
mortal technique,
he's here all the time,
all the time.
When you get out to la,
they're like,
oh shit,
he's here,
but I have a lot of family.
I'm always out here.
You just become a notorious and famous and norm or everything you've achieved
is,
I'm pretty much through the Internet.
Um,
a lot of it.
Yeah.
But I think in the very beginning it had to do with me going to specific places
and not just playing the big towns but playing all the small places around.
You think you built it up like a sort of a grassroots thing?
I through the Internet,
this business I learned his business from not only from people who were involved
in it,
but also like in terms of performers,
but I also learned the business from a lot of old school,
Italian and Jewish gangsters that ran the game back in the day and we're like,
hey listen,
let me just break it down for you young brother,
like in the 1930 [inaudible] the Jewish guy and talking to you like that.
We could have been,
hey,
let me break this fucking down fees.
That would bother you then.
Shit ever bothered the shit out of me.
We had to kill Biggie for a reason.
No,
no,
no.
I've been an old Jewish Jews brother.
I'm like,
oh,
they were very,
very,
and these are friends and family,
so it's not like they're sitting here playing a game with me.
They're just being very honest.
They're like,
look in in the 1930s and forties,
um,
people are African American,
didn't have the opportunity to petition in court.
I mean you didn't eat meat,
have civil rights.
So when you're dealing with people who are trying to rob you and jerk you in
terms of these promoters,
they needed some muscle for their hustle.
So it's different for them to be like,
hey man,
can I have my money please?
Or it like,
oh Louis Armstrong like $60,000 and you're going to give me an ivy over here,
an extra 10 for coming down here and having a fuck you up or you're not going to
have any legs in a little while.
Who the fuck are you going to call the cops?
When they used to have to do in the music business,
it was about getting money for the theaters.
No getting money from individuals shaking people down,
getting every last dollar that they could.
That's why business is run like a hustle.
It's run on some gangster shit.
If you look at the contract,
for example,
the one that used to be prevalent rather than three 60 deal,
you have a point system where you're basically given like,
you know,
10 15 points,
which technically means you get 10 cents off of every dollar that comes in.
So 10 points is a percent.
So the stuff you pay back in terms of the loan doesn't come out of the gross.
It comes down to come.
It doesn't even come out of the net.
It comes out of that 10%.
It's the most gangsta shit in the world.
It's a wow.
10% comes all of the uh,
Trower today traveling.
That's ridiculous.
The amount of,
uh,
of studio time evenly distributed between everybody,
right,
exactly.
Only goes
to the artists.
To me.
It wasn't just that,
but they also told me,
listen,
if you want to survive and have longevity in this game than do it,
the old school rock and roll way,
forget this,
this mix tape craze that was hitting during the,
the,
the mid two thousands.
They said what you need to do is Tor,
Tor,
tor nonstop go everywhere.
Never turned down a show.
So what did you,
uh,
were just starting us off?
Where'd you look to start doing rap?
Uh,
I mean I could rom ever since I was about like nine years old,
but I didn't really take it seriously.
Um,
like in terms of trying to put things together and puts like actual,
like around when I was five,
I did some doctor Seuss.
The Pixel put some real,
no,
but I,
when I was young,
I tried to ride,
I'll try to write like little songs or oh,
little verses.
And then I think when I got out of prison I decided,
you know what,
I'm going to take all these songs that I wrote while I was incarcerated and I'm
going to,
I'm going to really record them and I'm going to put them down.
I'm going to find instrumentals.
And I went about it and I started winning a lot of these MC battles.
They still have them one now.
They have like uh,
some companies that run them smack and you know what's funny man,
when dudes lose their hat and punched the other guy,
have you seen some of that shit?
I know a lot of people that have done things like that.
We,
we,
we shun those things in New York now.
They built a strong empire.
We vetch if you sucker punch of guy where the guy's going off on new year,
a weak bitch.
If somebody's getting in your face and like literally like touching your face,
you've crossed the line.
That is true.
But there is some shit that someone could say that they deserve to get cracked.
Like,
if someone's talking shit about your mother or you know,
or especially if whole point in a battle scene did a battle scene.
Now there's nothing that's off limits.
Yeah,
but it should be.
No,
and I knew he was gonna Punch you.
That's,
I feel like his mom dies.
But that's it talks the best.
Mom Joe,
this is the difference between how it is now and how it was back in the day when
I was around still doing these battles in the late nineties early 2000 and it
really only in the early 2000 is it on video.
All the other stuff was just street battles.
If you set something in a battle,
you had to be prepared to back it up afterwards.
Whereas now you could say,
I'm going to murder you,
I'm going to kick you out.
And then after the battle people shake hands and no mention of what's actually
transpired.
So in the old days it was more real.
Yes,
it was more than a murder.
Someone they might fucking shoot you when you are all here in a big cipher back
in like 1997 or something.
And one of us on someone tried to jump into cipher.
Somebody would test that person like,
what the fuck are you doing here?
And start battling them and whether or not they were successful or even held
their own in the battle,
they could stay in the Cypher.
It was more exclusive.
People booed the shit out of you before and we're not scared to.
Whereas now they're like,
oh yeah,
well he tried,
you know,
no,
fuck you get off stage in New York was just the worst.
Have you ever heard of Pete Spratt?
Do you know what Pete Sprout is?
That name is familiar and he's a bad ass rapper who's also a badass mixed
martial arts fighter.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He fought in the UFC a few times.
He's a fought and MFC.
Fun Bunch of different organizations,
but he's a sick Muay Thai fighter.
He's a but just bad ass.
Kickboxer very,
very dangerous dude.
But he's also a rapper.
It was like a rapper.
Yeah,
it was like Doh.
Last dude that you want to talk shit to in a fucking rap battle is Pete Spratt.
That motherfucker will leg kick you into oblivion.
I found her old rap battle.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
When you're doing this is all like ad libbing is pretty much freestyling.
You know what I mean?
You,
you have shit that you like go to like go to things.
I think every rapper has an emergency line but back in the day it really was
really,
really like very spontaneous.
It was off the top of the head as they refer to it freestyling off the top of
the head
I think.
And then I think at some point nowadays all the battle rap that we see now,
Joe is all very much choreographed.
Like in other words you and I,
it's,
it's run more the where the UFC would be where you and I know our opponent
months ahead of time,
we train for his style.
I see you and I say,
you know what?
His style is to find angles and personal lines about people.
I know what his weaknesses are.
I need to find it.
Whereas back in the day,
you would come in a room and the the wall would just be wall to wall MCS and
they would call to people to come in the middle that didn't even know each
other.
And then like you said before,
you were at war with a stranger.
I don't know.
It just,
they tell you that old battle rapping in 10 minutes,
settle it all Jujitsu,
stop shutting it down,
lay down some mats,
shut the fuck up.
But at the same pair of shorts,
put a tee shirt on,
ready,
try to kill each other to shut up.
But it's a war.
But that's the whole point.
It's a war.
It's a war of words.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But it's more of insults,
like personal insults at some point,
I think if you don't make the insults clever and there is no technique to them,
right.
And there's no metaphor and it becomes anything because you wouldn't,
you wouldn't.
And anybody else could have a slug fest in a street and eventually somebody's
going to win.
But there's no technique.
There's no,
there's no
in your wraps period.
Isn't it better to do that than to do it in some sort of a fucking silly battle
situation?
We insulting each other.
I think to me battling is something that refined and the,
the way that I,
I did rap and just to clarify,
there's a big difference between the way it was and the way it is now,
Joe.
The way it was was that the winner got to come back and perform at the next one.
You have to win two battles.
The first one was against your opponents and there would be several in the same
night you would have a pen.
Then you got to come back and perform your songs and music,
so you had to prove yourself twice.
The first time was against the other and the other one was against the crowd and
nowadays what's been taken out of the Joe is that advancement,
somebodies career
that that work that puts in that says,
you know what?
Not only did you come here and prove yourself in terms of you're insulting
ability to now I have to see are you really?
Can you really write songs right?
Is it really is it,
it's all you can do battle because if that's all you can do,
then step to the left motherfucker.
So someone that really has an opportunity to shine and and worked on music can
be in this position and show that to the crowd dudes that only have like a
battle rap game.
They don't have like a rap game.
I mean I threw,
I threw a personal battle,
which uh,
there were two winters,
there was a guy a called Nestle in a class.
Big shout out to them and what their battle was was for the opportunity and
they're going to have it now to open up for a short tour that I'm going to do
like a spot day tour for the middle passage.
So in that respect,
yeah,
they have to win a battle against one another.
And then the prize is I have to now prove myself in front of this audience.
I have to show them my work and I have to show them that I'm more than just a
battle rapper.
That's the biggest battle for me for any battle rapper.
When does that actually become a real writing to prove,
you know what,
I'm more than just a funny guy who can come up with insults similar to the way
comedians struggle to get a show or they struggling to get the actual
correlation as Comedians at work,
the crowd,
right?
Comedians at work,
the crowd versus communities and tell jokes cause you could,
there's some guys that is as a art to making spontaneous humor up and then where
are you from sir?
And you know,
fucking around with people in the crowd.
There's an art to that.
But there's a lot of dudes that get good at that and they can never turned it
into a bit.
They can never just go up there and without interacting with people.
Say,
this is my thoughts on things and have it be funny.
They just can't do it.
They don't develop that skill.
They just steel material from,
no,
that's another,
that's another thing.
But there's a,
we know,
dude,
that's a funny guy and he doesn't,
uh,
it doesn't do any real comedy.
Just talks to people just,
I mean,
if he can't talk,
but the crazy thing is you can't do that if you're doing 2000 people and you're
10 feet in the air and they're way down at the bottom.
You've got to have some bits
and that's exactly,
I think that analogy is pretty on spot because if you're not battling somebody,
there's nobody in front of you.
You gotta be able to make it out on your own.
It's like,
what if you don't?
What if you're that comedian that doesn't have that one person in the crowd that
came with a stupid hat and you're not.
You can't make fun of nobody no more.
Now you have to come up with something original and idea.
That's all your own that you own,
that Jen you put down,
which is technically what you're doing when you make soul.
Well,
a lot of them actually.
Yeah,
do
what they do is they fake that they're talking to the crowd.
They are talking to the crowd,
but they have like,
you know,
this guy says is a fireman.
I got some Goto shit for that.
You know,
if you guys are,
you're from Chicago,
I know what to say there.
You know,
there's like,
they have like a bunch of shit that they can go to.
They're just like plugging it into the audience and because it seems so
spontaneous,
it actually seems funnier.
It seems like it's like a little trick and it's good to fuck around with the
crowd sometimes.
I don't,
I actually don't mind a little bit of it every now and then,
but there's a big difference between the kind of work that's involved in just
add living on the fly and actually writing some shit and making it a bit.
Some people can't do both.
They can't that,
that transition.
So that's like,
I guess like a battle rapper who can't be a real rapper.
Right.
To me,
um,
me and my brother,
a poisoned pen.
We,
uh,
I'm,
I'm helping him right now in terms of,
um,
with some sponsorships and whatnot.
But mostly it's just been him that's been resurrecting a lot of these scenes and
he's very humble dude.
My brother poisoned pen.
He doesn't like to say that he came out and invented the idea of having paper
view battle rap.
He doesn't like to say that.
You know,
if somebody wants to come and battle in New York that he'll guarantee that
safety to make sure nobody touched them.
And until all the other goons,
yo listen,
he's,
he had a battle.
You put a thing going him,
you would have to answer to me and everybody else in in a squad and they already
know what it is.
But I think so nobody comes over here and gets her ass kicked.
Really have to be a real fuck up.
And you know what I mean?
We guarantee people safety in New York because it's good for them to be and we
won't be able to come to New York to battle.
Imagine if there was comedy clubs we had guaranteed.
People say,
well you got to man up guarantee their safety in order to do stand up.
Whoa.
There's a little bit,
there's a little more of a street element I think involved in,
in battle rap because you have
a little tiny,
just a tiny bit more.
So what I think,
uh,
I think you'll find that there's a diverse amount of people that are battling
like a diverse group of people now that are battling as opposed to it just being
two people talking about guns from the same neighborhood you have all into,
you have Asian,
Latino,
Jewish.
Why?
Swiping goes on.
We'll do it.
Swipe dudes wraps.
How much biten material.
Lotta Shit.
Huh?
There's some binders out.
Their bite is out.
There's some mother fucking listen to me.
Y'All live.
We're live right here on the Joe Rogan experience with a mortal technique.
Dez,
some biters out there.
There's some people who can't find a style of their own or they don't have
anything going for them.
Know what those people think I can do with themselves.
Leech off this snickering and they're fucking themselves.
Really?
Because you don't know how good it feels to write some shit.
You know,
when I write some shit and performing like woo,
there's just came to me from the university universe told me and I'm doing the
right thing.
So it gave me some inspiration that gave me an idea.
I put in the work and I got a result and it's just feels tremendous.
They don't get that.
They don't get that feeling.
So it's like this hollow,
empty whore,
like whole feeling,
you know,
fill the hole then and fill the hole that under.
They're not really creating anything.
It's fairly fascinating.
It's kind of a fascinating way to live life.
It's gotta be a weird hollow,
empty feeling.
But you know,
in the same,
in the same respect when comedy has ghost writers for example,
is different.
That's a job.
You know,
when a guy put together,
I know some great comments,
but there aren't,
but they're all people in battle rap and they're all people in rat period.
We have plenty of ghost writers as well.
And I'm wondering,
I don't think that thing wrong.
Does that take away from,
but that's the interesting thing to you.
It doesn't because in the culture of comedy where you have somebody like a Paul
Mooney who wrote for Richard Pryor where you have somebody like a,
maybe a Jeff Ross who now write vote for this person or that that's seen as as,
okay,
that's acceptable.
That's great that these,
the grades like Chris Rock,
Chris Rock used,
uh,
the Nick Depaulo,
Jeff,
rob,
rich vos rather,
he used,
well,
they're funny comics.
They're great comics and bounce ideas and those ideas often helps ideas.
I think in hip hop domains,
it's,
I think that's looked down upon a lot more than it is anywhere else.
It's like it's the kind of elephant in the room that people don't accept.
Well,
there's a lot of people in comedy that don't accept it either.
Like guys like Louis C K writes his own shit every year,
every year.
He writes his own new hour every year and he's one of the rare guys that does it
now.
He does it,
he does it while he's actually doing a television show to that.
He also edits and produces,
he's a maniac.
I don't know how the fuck does that.
It's really incredible.
He's a based on a mouthful pill.
That is what do we know?
He's basically obsessed with doing great shit and the results have been so
spectacular.
He's just continuing on that,
that obsessive path.
It's amazing.
He's just shouting out,
shout out to Louis because that's what I do.
I write all my own rhymes.
Nobody come up in and it says,
Hey,
you should rap rap to this beat or you should write about that.
It has to be those that I do that I don't,
I don't never really accept ideas from people,
but that's because I have my own shit.
I'm trying to work out already.
It's not that their ideas aren't great,
but just at a certain point in time I like to have it all come from my head and
there's a difference in between taking something that's kind of half done and
bouncing it off.
People you respect and being like,
you know what?
This is half done,
right.
The rest of it for me,
I'm,
I'll be bad comics give each other taglines to like,
that's one thing that's really cool that I really liked doing.
I like doing that for so like someone comes off stage and you're like,
what if you said this at the end?
I'm like,
Oh shit,
it's fun.
And then when you do it,
it's cool because like if somebody gives you a tag line and then you do it,
it's like,
it's like a shout out to your friend every time you're on stage.
It's kind of cool,
you know,
I don't even remember the bit,
but somebody gave me a great tag line once and I wouldn't always think about
them every time I would say I don't like it was my friend,
you know,
hooked,
hooked my bid up with a little extra punch.
Little extra thing that that's a thing that comics will do for each other.
The rappers write raps for each other.
Yeah,
all the time.
Like if someone like here's you doing a rap and then says,
oh,
did you know that that rhymes with booty?
No,
no I don't.
I think it's more like,
you know,
for example,
if you're signed to a major and you wrote a song and they like it,
they can take your songs since they own your intellectual property and you're
assigned to them and they can give it to someone else being like,
Oh yeah,
you wrote this song for you for like Jay are whatever and we're going to give it
to this wrapper.
It's funny,
they used to be valid.
That was like a real business.
It's like when you look at what a record label is now,
when you talk about something that's been diminished,
it's them in the porn industry have been like the most diminished because of the
Internet.
Fuck yeah.
All of a sudden it was,
you have a digital versions of everything you do and it's,
you don't need to go to a CD store where he might brush elbows with somebody in
a trench coat.
Uh,
uh,
some common baby come number seven,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like crazy.
So boot,
cocky,
flick in like a sick person.
And also I think those places where embarrassing cause you,
you knew who was watching what kind of shit but what kind of aisle they were in.
If you were walk by you were like,
oh you're elected chairman urine,
the German shit crazy section.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Yeah,
you don't want to hang out with that guy anymore.
Even if it's like its own private thing.
It's like you're in the shit.
I,
I've never went to that kind of place.
Would anybody stop
business?
Got To destroy that business in the music business it used to be like the only
way to get famous was you had to get on the radio.
But now the internet is really completely bypass that cause a radio.
You know the radio only works when you listen to the radio.
The union.
That is a part of everything everyday.
It's getting so weird,
man.
My,
my Twitter is so strange to me because I'm finding that I'm more shit through my
Twitter,
through people sending me things about the latest discoveries about Egyptian
boats that they found from,
you know,
all the things they found Atlantis and know there's a new discovery,
gorillas have figured out how to,
you know,
stop traps and disarm traps.
We find this shit.
It's like a constant barrage of insane shit and information you're getting from
people all day long.
Like this is,
this is so new to humanity.
Like we're not even sure the effects this is going to have on human beings just
in the next 10 or 20 years.
Like what people are going to be like with this incredible access to
information.
I mean,
I battering us with the reality.
I put her on the Latin and Sauna.
We opened up the show with,
you know what I mean?
I speak to those,
That that had become socially autistic.
Is that where society's heading now?
There are people,
I don't need to interact with you if I don't want to.
I'm here because that's the type of dude I am.
I'll come to the show,
but everyone seems to be able to want to call into life.
You know what I mean?
You meet more people on the Internet that you're going to meet in real life.
You meet course.
Yeah.
You would never have the opportunity to meet hundreds of new people instantly.
Right.
And then you or or you have access to information or you know,
you don't send letters no more.
You send an email,
you know what I mean?
You don't call nobody no more.
You Skype with them.
You know what I mean?
In some ways there's benefits to that.
It creates the ability to communicate with people.
But what kind of communication?
Because I've known individuals to severely misconstrue a text or an email before
that they can't get from a personal,
like I look at you,
there's something about the way you stand that tells me what your intentions
are,
the way you move in.
I think even in race relations,
this,
this works because if people who have been exposed to different races and
different cultures of people,
they look and see,
okay,
someone's rolling up on walking down the street.
You know,
he's not a criminal type.
He looks like this motherfuckers lost.
I would be like,
Yo man,
you know the,
the highways around the corner as opposed to being like,
oh,
because they're from here,
they're probably planning this or that.
Rather than looking their actual actions
of stance,
like in terms of,
of of a regular conversation,
your tone of voice,
you know what I mean?
The way you look at Africa,
again,
you know,
people have to treat everybody else's.
If it was you live another life,
then you wouldn't have to worry.
He'd realize this guy's cool.
It's cons,
it's concept.
The problem got dammit.
I said that it needs to be our new motto.
We're America and we're not cunts and everything we do.
That's conti.
Go stop doing it.
That's conti shit man.
I mean,
unless people are making billions of dollars off,
you got to stop.
You know,
they won't stop wanting to lose $1 billion a year and you don't have to be a
cunt.
Wouldn't you be happier and you're happy to do in your business making half as
much having a 1000 foot yacht instead of a 2000 foot yacht.
That's victimizing the world where American capitalism has the spotlight on it.
Because let's say you and me,
I have a company that averages,
you know,
around $12 billion a year of growth,
revenue sales.
We're a success.
But then the next year,
you know,
and every year we keep getting a little bit bigger.
You know,
12 billion.
You get into math and you spent all your money on hooker.
[inaudible] no,
no,
no.
I'm just saying one year,
imagine we make 11 billion,
you know,
not even,
not even gross.
We're talking about net right now and make an 11 billion.
What are we doing?
Are we selling anything?
It doesn't matter.
The point being just want to know what kind of businesses are successful.
The point being,
Joe,
is to,
to a lot of people in the business community and to the model of business,
we're a failure.
Now we're downsizing.
We're not going up from 12.5 billion to 13.
Now we're back to 11.
People like that.
Oh,
this business is on the decline.
We just made $11 billion.
That's just how they think.
You know what I mean?
If you're not always expanding,
if you're not buying new people,
if you're not buying new resources,
if you haven't obtained a good,
uh,
rapport with a government that makes,
you know,
labor laws and very,
very simple for you to deal with,
then you're a failure.
And I think that's what needs to change too,
in order for people to see themselves and other individuals.
Yeah,
there's gonna be some Karma free ways to do things.
You know?
And I've always said like,
we need to figure out a car,
my free iPhone,
we find out what's really involved in getting the minerals to make iPhone.
So like,
well,
this is fucked up too.
May very well be some children in the Congo who are scraping the mountains for
minerals that goes into your iPhone.
Like there's gotta be a way around that.
Is there a way around that and wouldn't what we would,
how much would you be willing to pay for an iPhone that's not manufactured and a
Chinese suicide factory?
You know how to help.
I mean these,
these places where they have nets set up in between buildings,
cause so many fucking employees have committed suicide.
They have actually done this and people say,
well actually the amount of people that commit suicide in these places,
it's very similar to the amount of people that commit suicide and real life.
Well,
you know what?
The differences,
that's not real life.
That's their job.
How many fucking people commit suicide at work?
You know,
I,
you don't want to talk about despair.
They're living in crazy dormitories and they're dropping off the roof into
concrete to end it.
Well,
I mean,
they're in a dorm.
That's basically,
I
mean we're talking about today.
Anything that would be anything.
Okay with that as Chris Somebody,
I'm not criticizing China,
the whole China,
but I'm saying,
look,
if you don't like prison here,
you don't like the legal system here.
You're really not going to like it in China.
You know what I mean?
We're talking about a government that is very authoritarian.
Something that the u s I think really kinda envies the ability for them to just
tell people to shut the fuck up about things like,
listen dude,
we're doing all of their Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
Oh,
you're gonna see you're gonna complain.
Shut up now the button's been pressed and everyone shuts up.
You know what I mean?
Olympics or,
Hey,
I take dog off the menu everywhere.
Every,
I don't want to see it because these people from Europe and America and as best
friend,
you know what I mean?
You,
you,
you might shoot a Nigga,
you won't go to jail.
You fuck with a dog?
Yeah.
That's the white man's best friend and you're going to jail,
dude.
You know,
that's what I did.
They made them Niggas.
They found all these different species of dogs and in Germany and in all these
other places during the Middle Ages,
they bred them to be what they are today Chinese people adopt funding and then
someone decided that they tasted really good.
I bet they do.
I don't know.
I've had rabbit.
I've never had rabbits.
Delicious.
I've never had dogs.
Don't tell Eddie Bravo though cause go crazy.
Eddie Bravo loves ramen.
It's all good.
Picks their animals.
Me,
I'm a dog man,
but I'm just saying like to me it,
if,
if we're at a point where society is just unwilling to move,
then what's the only thing that can rectify that?
A cataclysm.
You think the only thing define
it as information.
We got two people have to change.
You have to change who the fuck you are.
If you are a person that's part of the problem and you're aware that you're part
of the problem,
you've got to find a path away from that.
But if the real problem is you get addicted to life,
you get caught up in a system where you have a mortgage and you have car
payments and you have credit card bills and you have the,
you know,
this is worked ass,
this is for food,
this is for,
and you have these numbers at you have to achieve on a regular basis.
So there's almost no way you can detach yourself from the system and then start
off with some in some new path.
It's like you need constant income.
Have you have a family and need constant income.
If you have a mortgage,
you need constant income,
you know,
and that's how most of us are stuck.
Most of us are stuck cause we sort of got on some sort of a path and then we
became involved in the system due to financial necessity.
It's like no,
I mean you're not going to go home less.
You're not going to have your fucking kids be poor just because you have a dream
of trying to make it as an author.
You know you're going to have to find a way to do both of them at the same time.
You're going to have to find a way to work around it.
You can't just detach yourself from the system.
That's why so many people have a hard time changing.
Yeah.
That's why so many people have a hard time changing as they don't have the time
for reflection and when people are caught up in any sort of fanatical pursuit,
especially financial fanatical pursuit,
it becomes about ones and Zeros.
It becomes about numbers.
It becomes about adding Zeros to the ledger.
It doesn't become about your own personal growth and you as a human being trying
to find yourself in a better place in this world.
It doesn't become about that.
That's the real issue.
The real issue is the numbers trick you into thinking that they're real instead
of thinking that because they are real,
you can get things from him.
Real things like a house that you can knock on.
You could get a car that you get and you knock on that car.
That's a real car.
So there is something real that you get from it.
But essentially you're,
you're,
we've decided that those things are,
that you can get those things from money.
We've decided that we've all,
we've all decided that.
And because of that,
because it's broken down to a number thing,
then that becomes the grand pursuit.
The grander soon becomes this crazy idea that you need to stock pile numbers at
the expense of humanity and that humanity shouldn't be put at the very forefront
of any of the decisions.
So all of this could've been avoided.
Everything could have been avoided if any company realized that humanity has to
be first.
So if you're poisoning rivers,
if you're,
you know,
fucking people at Olin,
you cannot operate like that.
There must be a humane way to progress and do business.
If it only involves littering,
it only involves polluting and it only involves murder.
Well then that's ridiculous that this,
this shouldn't be a task that's,
that's taken forth by people.
But because of the fact that you can get ones and zeroes from those things,
the ones and Zeros of tricked us into thinking that that they are the end all be
all by providing us with real things that come from the ones and Zeros.
They have sort of figured out a way to hijack our system,
but we have to realize that solid things don't mean shit if you don't have your
humanity.
So it's not about ones and Zeros,
it's about humanity first.
Then it's about should humanity engage in this pursuit?
Should humanity,
you know,
a drill oil off the coast when it can fuck up like that and ruined square miles.
It was,
there would be nothing wrong with it.
This was a perfectly right and then we find out that it was all about ones and
Zeros.
The reason why it happened in the first place is because the company that was
building the,
well,
they cut a few corners because they were trying to make a deadline and they put
a less effective sort of a system in place and then it fucking exploded and
killed people and fucked up everything.
For a long ass time.
Why?
Because of ones and zero's not because of humanity.
You know,
it's the same thing with Fukushima.
people look at this reactor failing and melting down and there's all sorts of
scientific,
you know,
uh,
explanations for why it all went wrong.
But the bottom line is you shouldn't make something like that.
If you can't shut it off,
you couldn't.
You shouldn't make something where if the power goes out,
the whole place is fucked for a hundred thousand years.
That's crazy.
And that's a ones and Zeros economic situation.
I think when you told him about an element though,
that has been refined,
we told them about you too much nuclear power.
We're talking about when you're talking about uranium,
you're talking about plutonium,
all of these elements that are created by me and kind of these isotopes,
they're generally unstable.
He might have the same number of protons and electrons,
but it's the neutrons that flow out of them.
Well,
I always thought was interesting is how did the neutrons,
no,
just to leave that there just too many that we all just don't fit.
Or did they take anybody's bullshit?
Neutrons just bounced the focus and it creates an unstable element.
That's even toying with that.
Even toying with something like that,
you don't know because it doesn't have a stable physical property.
There is no shut off.
Well that's what Zoe,
to cool it off apparently.
Yeah,
they had to,
they had to use a or whatever these water,
ocean water and not really caught on and they don't know what the fuck is going
to happen.
I mean the whole thing is insane and it all happened because someone thought
that they could profit from it.
They needed power,
they needed to supply all these people with power and that became the way to do
it.
It's just seems so nutty.
It seems so incredibly nutty and it's,
but it's either that or we're going to do,
are you going to Cole,
you know,
fucking,
have coal factories and fuck up the environment even more.
And then which one are you going to go with?
We need some electricity bitch.
Right?
Someone needs to figure out a better way than that.
Solar energy.
But we get tripped up g and he's one ways we get tripped up and get caught up in
this one way and we think that's the only way possible.
You know,
I don't know what the fuck the Egyptians did,
but they did something,
they did something that allowed him to move these giant blocks of stone.
Like what the fuck were they doing?
Our dance slave?
Thousands of people and until then I'm going to move that stone.
Yeah,
but it doesn't matter.
Even if they did that,
how the fuck they pull it off.
Even if they had thousands they had,
but they had engineering.
I think at that particular time.
What we fail to see and we fail to realize is that,
look,
all of the documentation that they had was lost in countless amount of wars.
It's been still libraries of Alexandria was actually Bryan.
They're burnt down twice.
We'd lost all that information,
but it still doesn't,
it still doesn't any in any way to answer the question,
how about fuck did they do that?
Because what you're looking at it as something that we can do right now.
I mean there's a lot of those pieces that we can go right now.
You know what I mean?
It's just cut from a Corey,
it was miles away and these motherfuckers moved these thousand ton stone blocks.
Like how about the Acropolis where the Parthenon is under one of these?
It's under the Parthenon,
rather these huge fucking stones that no one has.
No one has any idea how they moved them there and no one has any idea how old
they are.
They just somehow or another someone cut these giant stones and put them into
place and you just go walk at.
But I mean when you go down to South America,
you go to see the Incas,
you'll see that too.
It Machu Picchu,
absolutely perfectly credible work.
They were cut by lasers.
How Boston is a pool and punk.
Cool and all that shit up in Peru.
It's,
it's amazing.
Or how does it heads on Easter island get there and all that extra curricular?
Sure.
Yeah.
Well not only that,
they found out those heads aren't just heads anymore.
They started digging underneath him and there's whole bodies to those things.
Whole bodies in.
It's interesting because they're not weathered,
so they get to see the much more intricate carvings like the sea,
like their hands and shit.
But the body's go like way down low.
There's a been a whole field of study now.
Now they're,
they're really kind of tripping out about how it seems very suspect that they
just didn't
look at that before like,
oh really man,
because it's so,
it's farther down.
Yeah.
Two things.
One,
it's they didn't have the technology.
I don't think to measure the earth.
I shovel.
No,
no seismic.
Because if you just dig down like that,
you could fuck it up.
You can fuck up the site.
And when they do that,
you're supposed to do it like microscopically when you like,
like this thing that they're doing in Turkey,
this go Beckley tapping.
This is,
is uh,
one of the oldest known structures that's w it was at least 13,000 years old and
it was built by people who they thought were like,
at the time they will hunter and gatherers.
It throws a big monkey wrench into that because there's this huge stone columns
and it's,
you know,
nine foot tall stone columns with,
exotic animals carved into them.
Incredible,
incredible work.
And it's all from 13 plus thousand years ago and it was all filled in 13,000
years ago,
artificially filled and humanity is thousands of years old and you probably
think it is much more.
So what's nutty about this one is that they've actually found that somehow or
another was buried and they purposely buried at 13,000 years ago.
My point was they've only,
they've only been able to explore a tiny percentage of this site because when
they explore it,
they use like fucking toothbrushes and shit cause they're like,
they're looking for any little thing.
They don't want to dig in with a shovel and break a bone.
That could have been a skull,
you know,
they don't want to fuck up.
So they're,
they're doing everything nice and slow.
So they've only uncovered like a very small percentage of this place.
So it's not suspect that the Easter island guys never dug into that because if
they did,
they do really precise.
I mean like,
like I said,
I mean it's not saying it's just seems like stone.
Yeah,
it seems like it.
Like if there,
here's the land right here and then they're probably like,
hey look,
it's,
it's still going down.
Let's go.
Like,
I mean these things have been in here for sorghum and Brian,
but you got to understand when they did find that,
when they initially found them,
they were so shocked.
They were so big in the first place.
They couldn't figure out how people made though.
It's not even the head,
but how did they get that stone there?
They don't know where it came from.
I mean it came from somewhere on the island obviously,
but help dog getting invited.
That's one of his little homie.
You take some other,
there's other pictures of them.
If you find them online,
they're pretty interesting.
There's a a lot of the work that's been dedicated to that now and then trying to
figure out how the fuck they did it and what it's supposed to represent.
Two,
why are they doing the same guy like that over and over and over again?
Who was that guy?
And of course that's where the ancient aliens come in.
You know those dudes,
those Giorgio sucralose,
Dude's we've had him on a podcast a bunch of times.
I love that.
I heard Katy Perry wants to meet him.
Like there was this thing like a report the other day.
Imagine if we,
we made it,
her and him hook it up and then he replaced Russell brand.
No Way.
If they met,
we met her and then we still heard from George.
Do you want to Steal Katy Perry?
Get out of here.
So yeah,
I want 20 period.
Her Beta boyfriend that travels around tour,
that's going to do it.
You don't want that.
You don't want that Gig.
She'll force you to get fat again.
I don't do it.
Did we talk,
did you talk about on on a podcast about how hilarious that Tim Tim,
Hi decker has been a d
going off on Russell.
We didn't talk about it.
Right.
And Russell brand's an English guy who's a really funny actor.
He's really funny and I'm getting into the Greek dude,
right?
Yeah.
I didn't see that movie,
but I loved Him in the Sarah Marshall Movie.
Uh,
but he's,
um,
apparently he's got a talk show and uh,
every time it's on Tim,
Hi decker destroys it.
He just goes after it and like spend the whole hour like writing hashtag like
vomit,
like sarcastic shit about things not being funny.
Hashtag vomit,
you know,
just shitting all over in Russell brand.
Well,
his is obsessed with it.
I think his new show is,
I forget what it's called.
It's like something x or something like that.
Brand X.
Good.
Have you seen it?
No,
I actually not a big fan of his,
he don't like him as an actor.
I no actor.
I do like him as an actor,
but this is not an actor.
This is like some weird talk show,
isn't it?
Or something like that.
But the poster is so they have it all over sunset and it's just him like laying
back with his feet up and like,
I don't know.
It's,
did you see what someone wrote on a,
on one of the posters?
Graffiti where they,
right.
I'd Rather Watch Katy Perry's new movie.
There you go,
Katie.
There's some loyal fans.
What it says,
where is it?
Ah,
that's not the,
that gets,
this is a poster that they did it too.
Yeah,
he's wild.
Don't you get it?
He's English and wild.
Yeah.
But if you look at Tim High Decker's he does Tim and Eric.
I,
if you look at his Twitter page,
it's just one after another.
Just hilarious.
He just tamarind them tearing them up.
I guess a lot of a lot of people are saying is not very good.
Um,
he just don't like it.
I get to mediocrity.
He likes,
is he Perry is a warrior against mediocrity I think.
Yeah.
I think he's just trying to impress Katie.
I think so.
And I don't blame them.
It could be that too.
Maybe he's trying to get points saying,
Yo look your man don't like you,
don't appreciate you.
I'll appreciate you watched.
Look at me,
destroy Ya.
Your ex to maybe it could be a little bit of that.
You think,
wow,
why don't we ask him right now as you go and respond to us on sweater and mood
show,
we saying you want her just hollow.
I think he's just a champion against mediocrity that could make you think.
He just really genuinely thinks that guys sucks.
Why did they agree to that?
Why did he agree to that photo?
Do you have friends?
Cause they shouldn't,
but I think when you get enough money day,
uh,
you're just surrounded by yes men.
Yes man.
Is that really true?
I think there's a way to avoid that.
It's got to be some people that will say,
hey man,
you know,
like for example,
I have a lot of friends,
like what am I producer's name is Sao Paulo.
I've known his brother for over 30 years.
You know,
we,
we went to nursery school together.
If I'm on some bullshit,
he'll tell me like,
Yo man,
look dude,
get the fuck outta here.
Does he have to tell you that sometimes?
Yes.
We asked to tell me,
Yo man,
like when we were doing our last album,
like,
Yo man,
get the fuck up man.
We got to get this going.
We got to get this moving.
Like he's a good motivator when he's on it.
He was on some bullshit.
I'm the one that's got a him battle.
When you're on the road battle,
I mean,
you see it comes on a road sometimes.
It depends on what the dynamic is.
Like what I need.
I have different amounts of people,
um,
that will come like people from the rebel alarms.
It's possible
to not live your life with yes men,
but you gotta be,
you gotta be your own worst critic.
You gotta be your,
I mean,
a lot of people don't like to do that.
They don't like that feeling of being,
of introspective feeling of feeling,
of really analyzing yourself objective.
A lot of people don't like that.
That's why they need someone to check them.
Because you have to,
you can do it yourself.
Yeah,
You have to look at yourself.
But it's finding that time.
See for me,
that's where the isolation tank comes in.
You know,
I use a sensory deprivation tank.
It's like a thank you lion with water.
When I'm in that thing you,
there's nothing.
It's quiet.
There's no,
so I'm not seeing anything.
I'm not feeling anything.
I'm just floating in that water.
And when you're doing that,
you're forced to think about yourself.
You're forced to analyze your behavior.
It's like there's nothing else there to distract you.
There's no TV to watch to flood your brain with useless shit.
There's no email check,
just no Twitter to check.
There's no wall to stare at and look at a painting.
You know you're forced to be alone with your thoughts.
So you're forced to analyze your life.
And it makes me think that there's not a lot of time in life to ever achieve
that sort of same state.
The state of self analysis does not a lot of time to do that.
And if you're not analyzing,
then a lot of fucking you're doing just running around with slippery shoes on,
you know,
you're not getting anywhere.
You're fucking this thing,
you're not looking at it.
You're,
you're learning a little bit here and there,
but not as much as you could be if he just really spent a certain amount of
required time to just analyze your shit.
And this is again,
what people don't do.
So that,
and don't be a cunt or the two best piece of advices a human being could ever
get.
And yet those are also two pieces of advice they never give you.
That's really the simplest thing.
That's the only way we're gonna fix this world.
We're not going to fix this world.
I don't think through some new technology or through some actual genetic
evolution.
I think we're going to fix this world through or behavioral revolution.
And that revolution is you're going to,
we're going to have to start looking at each other.
Let me ask the other way.
The world can change and since we are in 2012 I'd be remissed from bring it up.
People are saying now that they'll be some kind of cataclysm at some point,
some cataclysmic event.
I think even though I don't necessarily agree that that's definitely gonna
Happen,
I always say that I can subscribe to the possibility of something like that
happened.
I've always said that,
but that's not the point.
Not y two k or the Mayan prophecy.
Just the point that if something terrible did happen,
isn't that the time when everybody seems to come together and it's not an 11 and
if that terrible thing was permanent and it wasn't,
we could just
pushed to the back of our memory and say,
hey,
I don't want to deal.
I don't want to get in the isolation tank and deal with the fact that yes,
we did sponsor a jihad against the Russians and when someone was blowing things
up,
there's some mom in Russia right now who cried over her dead son back in the 70s
and eighties and her pain is no different than any American mother that's,
you know,
suffering because their son died and I wreck at some point.
If we don't put ourselves in that isolation tech and say,
you know,
we can't escape this.
This is something permanent that has affected our are the real problems,
then we have to come together.
The problem is the word we,
and I was like,
who's actually doing this?
Who's actually doing very small amount of people that are actually in charge of
the heinous acts of the world?
It's really kind of fucked up.
Small amount of people put forth the motion of a large group of people that work
for the cause,
but it's a very small amount of cons.
It's really,
it's kind of incredible when you really stop and look at how fucked up the
world,
they slightly smaller people isolated.
Cons.
Yeah.
Like guys like guys like Dick Cheney.
Remember when he was in that bunker all the time deciding what Bush should do?
What the fuck was that about?
Dude would just hide in a bunker and we would just go up,
we're here,
Dick,
how do I know he's in the bunker?
I mean,
that seems really stupid.
I'm not even trying to find this out and I know that he's in the bunker.
You know what I mean?
What the fuck kind of weird shit is that?
Are you so confident and that God damn bunker listen to people like him are in a
position that they're in because they convince other individuals that their
moral leaders then somewhat like,
look,
this is my only thing in terms of Republicans and Democrats,
when we had this debate and we discuss it there,
they're both have to pander to corporations.
However,
my experience,
I've met a lot more conservative people that try to play pious and like,
oh,
that's so horrible and as opposed to saying,
yeah,
we're all part of this.
You know what I mean?
As opposed to just be who you want to be.
Instead you lie about who you want to be and then you're trying to pick men up
in an airport bathroom,
you're secretly selling arms to enemies.
Are you doing it and just just be who you are,
but at some point you couldn't be in that position.
You are unless you didn't convince people that you're a good Christian.
You know what I mean?
That you're a humble person,
that you care about other people when in reality you're probably not any of
these things and you've got into politics because it's a good fucking pay day.
Well,
it's also the power power to the reason why.
Well women and yeah,
the reason why anybody who wants to be president shouldn't be president.
He said nobody should want to be president.
Nobody would should want to be that guy.
The one guy that gets to decide everything how are giving you,
you're crazy.
You're out of your fucking mind.
The position shouldn't exist anymore.
It shouldn't be a way where one person is thought of as our great leader in 2012
it's nonsense.
That is,
that is a,
it's a,
a form of leadership,
a form of hierarchy that exists in small groups of primates.
Okay.
That Alpha Shit works with one person when there's like 50 people,
but I don't think that gotta be the bad motherfucker is a functional system.
Now.
I think that's the imagery the system gives you.
But obviously I know,
but I'm saying like you should be a cabinet,
but people have not just the cabinet.
He has a plethora of backers that have given financially to it and at the end of
every election he represents them.
Mother fuckers expect to get paid.
They expect to get what they gave.
You know what I mean?
Like if I make a fucking investment homie,
I want some returns.
This is what's going to,
you're going to do something for me.
I gave,
that's why Mitch Romney,
Romney is so dangerous with this medical marijuana should,
he's the most dangerous cause he says he'll fight tooth and claw to stop medical
marijuana.
Well of course too.
Of course you will.
Someone's paying you to do that.
SMART,
smart,
smart for you to get on that hustle too.
That hustle's a weak ass hustle that's a dumber hustle.
The Republican hustles,
Wade dumber because a lot of it is based on,
you know,
silly ideologies.
Look,
it's done.
People that don't want to think one in one of their primary selling points has
always been religion,
especially in the modern age.
And I would,
I would say more so after the Reagan era because one of the first presidents to
really bring out evangelical voters was actually Jimmy Carter and not any
republican really at first.
They always attributed to Reagan's administration as an actor.
We targeted them.
Jimmy had more of them.
Again,
south,
very Christian for humanitarian armor played that up very much so man of the
people.
But at at some particular point,
if we're incorporating your philosophy into and in with the corporate goals and
stuff,
I always thought about it this way,
you know,
if religion is that the selling point,
then let's sit in that tank where we move everything apart and we think about
humanity as a whole.
In Egypt 3,500 years ago,
people worship deities like a,
a new bid.
So Cyrus,
you know,
an anthropomorphic figure with the body of a human being and the head of a
jackal
or a or an apple.
No,
other than that and the highest fuck son.
That's why,
or they,
they just,
they prayed to these figures thinking that they were going to bring them food
or,
or love or long life or a cure,
right?
Everything that was real back then,
that's real to them now where that's fake,
then it's fake now.
But my thing is this,
if,
if we look at it from that perspective now as Americans,
like,
oh,
that's so ridiculous.
Somebody worshiping a statue like that with it.
Well,
that's 3,500 years from now.
If,
if humanity makes it 3,500 years from today and they look back at this time,
I know exactly what they'll say.
They'll say,
just as we said about those people,
look at these ridiculous,
pathetic human beings that lived at this time and they worshiped the dead guy
nailed to a piece of wood and they couldn't understand the most basic thing he
was trying to tell people,
which is treat others the way you want to be treated
or they worship the dude who you can't even draw or people want to kill you.
Right?
Or at any point took that,
took a position,
took a position that said,
I'm going to think to create the ability to just tell people something and not
have them question it ever at all.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the most dangerous.
Why not think about anything?
Because you should be able to say,
hey man,
if one of these things is a logical than all of them have to be.
If you're telling me,
Oh,
it's impossible for Jesus to have resurrected.
Okay,
but it's possible for man to divide the ocean for someone that the Prophet
Muhammad peace be on him,
ascends into heaven.
That's the same thing to me.
Or is the same impossibility.
But I think that when you look at people's lives who live in poverty,
the reason that that's so that's so prevalent there is because their lives are
so ridiculous because their lives are so insane that I couldn't understand.
But that's just as as outlandish to me as walking on water.
The idea that,
you know what,
I'm going to have to drink my own pissed today or I'm not going to fucking be
hydrated,
or I have to go for three days without food or,
or I have to cut pieces of my flushed out.
So you're saying that their life was so fuck that they,
the religion,
it was easy to give them religion.
Well,
I put it this way.
I'll give you a personal example.
Rather than using a hypothetical,
my grandmother whose house I just left,
well,
I just like I was telling him before I took it to Vons,
I always show grandma love.
I care about her a lot.
She raised 10 kids,
you know what I mean?
God bless her soul.
My grandfather,
God rest.
His soul was a,
was a good man in his later years,
but he fucked up a lot of things in his first year is so he wasn't around a lot
and I always think to myself like there's something about the idea that grandma
had that somewhere in the sky that that a guy named Jesus,
you know what I mean with the mullet and I'm the cut,
you know what I mean?
And the blue eyes was out there watching it and she depended on that idea.
I'm not trying to steal that love and compassion from anybody.
I'm not trying to take any religion away from people at all.
I just tell them all the time that unless your religion makes you a better
person,
unless it,
unless it makes you less judgmental over people's lives.
If it makes you more generous,
if it makes you look at people and say,
Hey,
just like you said,
you know what?
What if I was that person?
What if I grew up like that?
Then it's in noble June.
But if it makes you more pretentious,
if it makes you more of an asshole,
if it makes you say,
I just have the real truth and everyone who doesn't believe in what I believe in
is going to hell,
then your religion has failed you as much of you as you failed that religion.
In My,
in my humble opinion,
that's all I would say that without that connection,
it's an ideology and the cardiologists and answers questions that have no
answers.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's not,
not that there couldn't have been a Jesus,
not that he couldn't have been a girl came back from the dead and how the fuck
do you know?
I don't know Zach.
Okay.
If you,
if,
if there's,
you're talking about one magical act,
let's just go hypothetical.
Completely one magical act.
You're saying that magic can exist.
Is that what you're saying?
I don't,
maybe it can't right now.
Maybe it did at one time.
I mean,
isn't it possible that somewhere,
somewhere along the line,
so I'm going to figure something fucking crazy out.
Just like today,
they figured out the Internet,
just like today,
they figured out cell phones and bullets and laser.
The fuck knows what do I know?
But what I do know is that you're you,
you,
you can't make absolutes with human beings.
You can't tell me that you know the answers.
Because if you go back to a science book from 100 years ago,
almost none of it is like a medical book,
like medical science.
Almost none of it is applicable.
Like the things that used to do to help people 200 years ago,
300 years ago when they were sick or nothing,
anything,
right?
That's nothing.
And you're counting on the word of God from people who wrote it down more than
2000 years ago.
And by the way,
the oldest version of it is the Dead Sea Scrolls.
They wrote it on animal skins and left it in fucking clay jars in the hills of
Qumran.
And this shit is like a thousand years old.
Or then even the,
the oldest version of the ancient Hebrew Bible.
Well and they can't even,
they can't even acknowledge the present day New Testament.
They're saying they're having a debate now about what language it was in,
whether it was in Greek or Aramaic.
So even at that point we're talking about the inability to sit down and
precisely time something.
Yeah,
that's what a lot of people don't understand as well.
That ancient Hebrew was also,
uh,
they didn't have numbers,
so like the letter a doubled as the number one.
So,
and then words had like numeric value,
like the word love and the word God,
they have the same new numeric value.
And that was like important for the way they wrote things.
They wrote things not just with letters,
but numerically it's really trippy.
And apparently that's all lost in the translation of the Latin and Greek.
And there are regional,
but even Latin and Greek for example,
those ancient languages,
like,
like a Hebrew,
Arabic,
Latin,
Greek,
there are words that means several different things.
Sure.
I think it's just a testament to how basic our form of communication is that in
rap and lyricism,
I have to create wordplay,
double entendres things that have double meanings.
Dick's,
this,
that really means this,
this mansion Hebrew that a metaphor and a simile where those aren't even
necessarily in other languages because it's written into the actual words.
Like,
I could have a normal conversation with you in one of those ancient languages if
we were back in those times and then go,
maybe it was really fucking dumb.
And that's why they don't do it though.
One more.
It didn't come across right.
But I just know English being a very basic,
a dramatic and Scandinavian type language,
you know what I mean?
That's definitely in the difference.
English.
Yeah.
It's,
I wonder,
I wonder what it would have been like to have a battle rap in ancient Hebrew.
No,
but you know,
I read an interesting,
uh,
account of,
um,
ancient Greece and Byzantium at the time and it was said that the,
even the emperor Justinian,
they were different groups the way we have a red republicans,
Blue Democrats,
they had the Greens.
And Blues back then that argued for different political factions and it said
within several of these books that I read that even the emperor and other people
participated in some of these debates where it had to be at a certain tone.
It had to be at a certain
tempo,
like so in essentially they're politically battle rapping one another as a
speaker,
as a speech,
but it had to have rhythm to and hadn't had a poetic,
no kidding.
That's fascinating.
I mean what that was,
what do you think they rhyme things?
Is there any evidence?
So once the earliest evidence of people,
people figuring it out that it's cool to rom shit.
Probably when someone went,
oh no,
but I mean like what was there are,
they're really old rhymes,
like old poems that old poems always rhyme.
No,
I didn't drop it like it's hot.
drops it like a time for real.
When did rhyming start?
Who figured out rhyming?
Have somebody,
you're a rhyming expert.
You should know this immortal tech who invented funny.
That's impossible there.
We got every guide,
every monkeys laugh at each other.
He goes to sit to the zoo and one Champa hit another chimp with a lot of words
sound the same.
You never know who sat.
I know,
but I wonder when the,
the actual art of yeah,
it's writing things down and making them rhyme doing and correct and doing in
time.
Harry,
Mary.
Yeah.
Someone figured out that there was something cool about that because there
really is something cool about rhyming.
Shit.
It makes it better.
You gotta take a leak.
Yeah.
Straight out that door last door on the left,
we've got to show me yeah.
Show Friday dirty freaks and 30 Joe Diaz,
he said Yeah.
And Joey Diaz,
Josh Mcdermitt,
Brian Read
Banh Mi and a whole lot of other people that were friends with that stopped by
hopefully.
Um,
we don't know exactly,
uh,
what the lineup is,
but that's the lineup so far.
But it will be Friday night,
10 30 in the Ice House comedy club,
which is probably one of the fucking coolest spots on earth.
Been here since like 1950 something.
What was I just googling?
Was I looking at,
I was talking to him about something crazy.
I don't know.
You don't remember?
I know you pay attention,
the edible and all.
You sign up a bit after.
I eat that edible yesterday if people like do Joe,
you seem like you were on drugs yesterday.
Yeah,
that,
that was a weird one.
I ate more of it and I forgot I was just hungry.
I've been eating edibles a lot lately just because I have so many edibles now.
I'm hungry.
I'm like,
wow,
that is a Reese's cup.
I'm hungry.
You should get some food in your house.
Bitch know I really said,
um,
but being that high and listening to honey honey was really freakish.
Oh,
I bet.
Holy Shit.
They were good.
Yeah,
her voice is incredible,
man.
It's just,
it's mind boggling.
They're kind of like I was saying like you're making noise with your mouth and
it makes people feel better.
Like some weird thing.
I would love to be able to,
what do you love to be able to date a girl that could play an instrument and
sing like that?
I think that would,
I've never done that.
I think it would be different.
It'd be sexy,
but yeah,
it's definitely socks.
She would write you a song,
you know,
you know for your birthday.
I want to hear your fucking crazy song you wrote about me.
Silly bitch would have,
she was like crazy talented.
That would be really fucking bad for your ego.
Some check writing songs about you.
I think it would be amazing.
Yo Vain.
If it was good,
like her voice was really good.
This song is about you.
That was a bad ass bitch.
Carly Simon.
Yeah.
You gotta be really careful if you bang a famous singer and she writes a song
about your Warren Beatty.
People are really mad that he never answered who you thought killed.
Picky.
Fuck those people do.
You don't have to answer that silly cod damn question.
I got to get this is the real question is big foot reel.
I think at some point he was at some point and they don't exist anymore.
At some point he was.
I mean,
like we say,
it's possible in the Pacific northwest and Ip and undiscovered primate.
Never been there to the Pacific northwest looking for fucking prime meat,
but have questioned asked.
You definitely met some primates on the road that act at a place and you know
they,
they want to play monkey and they run into some real gorillas and I don't think
Dan is the same thing.
I think we're talking about a totally different,
no battalion definitely get the big foot.
They get that Sasquatch stomps as to what it is,
baby.
I think that's a good question to ask.
Almost anybody that comes in the podcast,
do they believe in bigfoot?
I started with [inaudible].
I didn't get to talk.
No.
I've asked like 10 people who killed.
What was their response when all the police
that was the rolling stone said it was a rampart unit,
wouldn't be the first time they shot him.
No fucking with no consequences.
Well not only not,
it wouldn't be the first mean back then.
You had to realize in the 1990s who essentially we were in the Non Internet age
people that had not changed from the old way it's shot on a strip of Vegas with,
yeah.
How many witnesses?
It's,
the Internet age has really changed a lot of shit.
It's not as easy to just pull something off like that.
It's different.
It's a different world.
And I think maybe,
you know,
did you ever see cocaine cowboys?
Got Damn,
is that a good movie?
God Damn.
Is that a good movie?
Um,
and uh,
cocaine cowboys too as well.
Just as good.
And anyway,
when they talked about that one class,
the graduating class of the Miami police academy where everyone who graduated
either wound up murdered or in jail for corruption,
every one of them,
they were just crazy gangsters.
The whole police department was karate.
That's amazing.
I mean,
we had some like that in Harlem called the dirty 30,
where they would just robbing drug dealers,
dirty cops.
They would just,
there was a saw such a gang and it was the 13th precinct dabbling.
I think what they did was that they would just continuously rob drug dealers,
harass individuals from one,
and they were extorting dealers at the time.
She's here was crazy.
One of my,
one
of my,
um,
one of my friends' fathers,
said that at a particular time,
the cops came in,
rated what he had and said,
you know what we're going to give you were taking the money,
but we're going to leave the stash and we're going to make sure nobody fucks
with you and we're going to give you extra stash here.
We got some more smack for you.
Press up,
do whatever you want,
and then we'll come back and we'll take a percentage and you can have
your whatever the fuck cut.
He said,
this went on for a couple of months and he was like,
Yo,
you know what?
Finally I'm out of this.
He said he don't even know what happened to his friend.
I was into it with is with five.
Oh.
He said basically,
you know what?
So the police made some sort of a deal where they would take a piece of the
action,
right?
Absolutely.
Ooh,
it's such a slippery slope.
If you're a competent start doing illegal shit,
you really can't stop.
I mean,
how do you stop and become a good cop again?
It's so hard for them to stop.
They,
you know,
it's plus drug dealers that have done a fuck about no badge,
Homie,
you stole $10 million from me,
I'm going to fucking kill you.
The Bauman,
Nickelodeon family,
just the person.
But at the end of the day,
you're just a person.
And that's,
that's the creepiest thing that a cop could think of is that they're in a gang,
you know,
is there gang versus your gangs?
But I mean,
keep it real.
That's what it is.
Kind of what it is.
You know what I mean?
You fuck with one of them?
They'll come get you and they're not playing.
You know what I mean?
Of course.
Yeah.
And you know,
that's why,
because that's why they look,
if they're protecting good people from crime,
that's all good.
It's when they become the people that are perpetrating the crime,
that that sort of a situation becomes a problem might be they become the
protector of those individuals.
Someone,
someone once said that they only exist in a society where,
you know,
you have such a distinction between poor and rich.
You know?
Then if people were equal in a society that you wouldn't,
they wouldn't have a best friend with people.
Being equal is freewill and activity and the environment.
It's like you would have to do a lot to make people equal and it wouldn't,
it wouldn't involve just the people who are poor.
It would involve everybody and it's,
it's the process of thousands of years of human behavior.
It's not a simple process.
This people that are always going to be lazy cunts and I don't know how you fix
that,
but when you give people,
this is the reality of a welfare state.
The reality of a welfare state is as a community,
we should always be willing to help our brothers and sisters and help people who
have experienced,
uh,
circumstances beyond their control and have a community like stand up for each
other.
You know,
when I,
you know,
I know people who are,
their houses burned down and their folks next door let him move into the
basement with her whole family until they rebuilt their house up again.
Like that kind of stuff.
It's the fucking beautiful.
I love hearing stuff like that.
That's human beings helping other human beings.
But there's a difference between that and then giving people something when
they're poor and they don't have to do anything for it.
That's this.
There's a real problem with human beings and when you get people used to money
for nothing,
they get lazy as fuck.
They have no reason to do anything.
It's just natural human behavior.
It's sort of,
it feeds into some baby shit that you,
and so these people,
without developing a character,
without develop and having everyone around them living in the same way,
so they're imitating their atmosphere and then having the situation where it
seems like there's no way out of it.
So it becomes a a point of despair,
a point of acceptance.
And this laziness becomes harder.
Culture Buddy to Shannon,
and then in essence is kind of a microcosm for what corporations get in terms of
their corporate welfare.
They're used to having
a government that that can fucking give money to,
that going to,
they can work with.
They're used to being able to grease palms in order to get things passed that
are illegal.
Yeah.
He used to say,
oh,
this is an illegal,
well guess what?
What is the fucking law if you can rewrite it because then that affects millions
of other people's lives.
To me,
when I look at,
at at the rich poor divide,
it was funny,
my grandmother said some,
some funny thing to me at the table today.
She goes,
you know,
rich people need to be in our prayers too.
And I said,
yeah.
He said,
Yo,
people pray for poor people all the time.
She told me,
he said,
but we need to pray for rich people too because unfortunately there God is money
and they're lost.
Some of them are lost and they just don't know what the hell they're doing and
how much they're hurting people.
Now mind you,
I'm not,
I'm not a religious,
you know,
and it wouldn't mean,
and then they're,
they're hurting people.
But no,
I'm not saying they're hurting people by being rich.
But if,
if you think that you can just solve everything with money and that is what your
primary focus is,
because unfortunately not trying to solve everything with mine and just trying
to rack up a good score,
but it's not even that it's now they think that that particular piece of number
behind them makes them better than other people and in some case score and in
some cases they can live up.
Oh actually,
well they do.
They live a much better life.
Well,
it's a game.
Capitalism as a game,
it's not in the capitalism is not the problem.
It's the abandonment of humanity while pursuing capitalism.
It's not pursuing a game.
It's pursuing a game,
but without any worries about the consequences of the environment or the human
costs.
I don't think we play real capital and [inaudible] capital is involved like
other people that have competition.
When we go to a country and we engage in a kleptocracy to take over things,
that's not real capitalism.
They don't have their own little African diamond company that competes with
doctors and the rest of them.
But what they have is a monopoly.
They might have the semblance of what capitalism is within the confines of
certain sectors of the United States,
but outside of this country,
real capitalism doesn't exist that way.
Our relationship with England and that capitalist relationship is the difference
from is very different from our relationship with let's say Columbia and that
relationship with capitalism where we say,
we're going to prop up a state buy.
It doesn't matter what the human violation of human rights violations are.
We're just going to prop you motherfuckers up and you're going to get us what we
want,
which is control of the particular region.
You have the the the Atlantic and you have the Pacific,
your neighboring country comes cons.
It really comes down to behavior.
It comes down to the same goddamn thing.
Everywhere you go,
you could wrap it up and capitalism where economic gain or call,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
The real problem is doing things at the expense of other people,
fucking people up.
It's not more than not.
People are rich and it's not the the problem with,
you know,
not going to have any equality until everybody's equal.
That's never,
no one's ever equal in this fucking world.
No one's going to be someone's,
someone's going to be smarter,
they're going to be fast.
Are they going to have a bigger dick?
There's no equal.
You got your fucking roll the dice don't needing to make hey mother fucker.
And that's,
that's what's missing in a welfare state.
And the,
the problem with the,
that everybody
has to equal,
no,
you have to work harder to be equal,
but you have to also have an even playing field,
which we don't even have that.
So it's not even that people are impoverished and there's a direct path,
but people,
people who are impoverished and there's no training,
there's no education,
there's no protection from their environment,
that the,
the violence of,
well,
because it comes with them,
then there's no interest in them making,
making them into exactly able fact as parts of society.
You know why?
Because they can make money for us and the prison system and this is what we're
in and also make money.
See that's just because that system's in control.
It's been hijacked.
You can make money from having,
look if you have money,
big money for defense contractors in Iraq and rebuilding companies like you
know,
like Halliburton,
they come in and build shit back up after we blow it the fuck apart.
Well then you could also have big contracts to see shape up ghettos.
You could have the same kind of build Detroit.
Exactly have the same kind of money involved in,
in putting forth some sort of an effort to,
to,
to fulfill their potential of young human beings,
to take young human beings in any sort of impoverished area where they don't
have a whole lot to look forward to.
They don't have a whole lot of options and provide those.
I've always said you want to strengthen the country,
make less losers.
Okay,
that's the,
you want less people robbing people,
less people in jail,
more people producing.
The only way to do that is to take care of the most important resource we have.
And that's young people.
That's babies,
that's children.
That's the lie.
And where's the life becoming the most fucked up?
Is it?
Well in the most impoverished areas,
it's the most difficult.
It's harder to get away from the grime,
the crime and the gangs and all.
Well,
we need to correct them and no politician has ever lifted a fucking finger for
that because they can't make money.
We have to figure out a way to make money and fixing things that we have to
figure out a way.
We're Halliburton gets on mushrooms and they go,
we're going to rebuild kiddos instead of going over to fucking Iraq and blowing
shit up and then rebuilding it back.
Let's rebuild,
you know,
rebuild the ghettos.
I think
the problem is that even if you wanted to do,
and even if they agree to do it,
they would always be some kind of hidden agenda there.
Like you know we're going to use,
because they're not on mushrooms,
mushrooms,
we're going to rebuild the ghetto so that we can turn all of these kids that are
coming out of here.
Fucking soldiers comments.
If you want to con you wouldn't do that.
So it goes back to my thing.
Don't be a beer gut.
That's everything.
That is everything.
It's the blue that doesn't teach that shit to put on a t shirt.
Somebody else do it right and they make some money.
No,
not just get like a little Buddha right down to teach.
It says,
Buddha says,
Don [inaudible] says,
I'm going back.
Don't be a con.
I think I'm going to have an American flag one.
And so it was going to say we're America and we're not comment because I think
that's even better.
That's the perfect ideal.
Everybody looks at America,
we don't look at it and man,
I'm an American.
And then the back it says,
but I'm not a cut that too,
but I think it's better to say it all in one sentence where America and we're
not,
or we have the best clients do we?
I don't think we've done girl cuts.
Brazil's got us beat.
No,
maybe Japan.
It's dirty.
Shut your fucking mouth.
Joe Is team Brazil.
That big shot at everybody.
Hold on,
hold on.
Big shout out to everybody that's listening from Brazil and from Japan and
people listening to us from everywhere.
Bookshop.
Brazil.
Big shout out to Tiawana.
I met a lot of people in San Diego that came up from Tiawana.
Tj.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a fucking long trip,
man.
You're a Mexican dude.
You want to go see some comedy?
They're like,
yeah,
right.
You got to answer some fucking quarter dogs.
Sniff your car for everything that ever has been invented.
All right.
You dirty bitches.
This podcast is over.
Thanks brother.
There was awesome.
Good time.
We're almost at three hours,
so at three hours are a podcast.
Becomes a pumpkin.
I wanted to,
I wanted to give you this gift for four.
We get out of here.
Okay.
What is it man?
This is a mortal technique tee shirt.
Oh Shit.
Brian's got one on right now.
Ladies.
Gentlemen,
a bang at a,
used to be go check out Brian.
I got the uh,
the album.
I just giving them an and the other albums and you got a desk squad tee shirt
on.
Sun Bang,
Bang,
Bang.
He's deaf.
Squad is the t shirts are available at desk squad.
Dot documentary movie.
It's with myself.
I'm also Cornell West ice tea krs one,
Chuck d,
Woody Harrelson.
Whole gang.
Mentoree.
On you.
Yeah.
And also it's about artistic freedom and stuff like that.
You can get it that viper records.com directed by my friend Carrie to dude,
you have your own documentary.
Yeah,
but we got,
that's pretty sporty.
Trying to,
trying to be as,
as focused as I got to be humble.
When you have your own documentary man.
It's a real problem trying to see,
get your own documentary man.
Sorry if I don't shout out the following people,
they go crazy.
Big.
Shout out to swaves seven diabolic.
These are the first shout outs ever.
South string of the Joe Rogan experience.
Hassan static Gi Joe j arch Chino XL bounded poison pen reb alarms forever.
You're already knows stronghold.
Big shout out
alien ware,
MMA follow Alienware MMA on Twitter.
They provided us with these bad ass computers,
but we uh,
we support them because they support mixed martial arts fighters,
a lot of fighters that are supported by Alienware.
And,
uh,
I just am a big fan of supporting companies that,
help out fighters,
especially guys up and coming and sponsored them and the Alienware dogs that so
thank you to them.
Thank you.
To honor Topcon go to o n n I t get yourself some Alpha brain son I was on at
the entire podcast.
Be like,
damn,
where's Joe Rogan coming up with the idea?
Tell you it's weed and Alpha brain.
We'd powerful brain and then that creates the octopus with the fucking shark has
shout out to all you silly bitches in the La city council that decided to ban
these medical marijuana dispensaries.
You all need to do some fucking yoga classes while you're high on a pot Brownie.
So you understand what the fuck you're blocking.
You're blocking evolution,
you're blocking love,
you're blocking,
you're blocking comradery and you're blocking medicine from sick people.
You're balking,
met her medicine that can cure cancer,
like cured Tommy Chung's fucking cancer.
You're making it difficult for something awesome to get around.
That's what you're doing.
You think you're protecting people from crime.
You're not.
You're just making it difficult for something awesome to get around.
Pot is awesome.
You need some fucking pot.
Everybody who wants to stop pot needs pot.
That's,
that's reality.
Pod is love.
God is love.
[inaudible] dot com get yourself some Alpha branch,
some shroom tech part of the history of America.
Don't deny it.
Don't deny dirty bitches.
Get of yourself some kettlebells and put in a fucking empty workout.
Get some battle ropes from ana.com get you smell on kid.
Increase your libido,
increased.
You're thrusting power.
You've got to have those strong lower back muscles to a hard fucking on
somebody.
What is this?
You're showing us half shark.
Half Octopi.
Oh,
there's a real day cards.
I know that's a no somebody.
I know.
Somebody who Larry is the fuck Outta here.
Oh,
this thing is awesome.
Shout out to olive garden.
Yeah,
shout out to all right.
On a.com pay subs will kettlebells.
We'll use the code name,
Rogan and you will save yourself 10% off.
Alpha brain shroom tech,
sport bones strong.
We've got a bone strengthening supplement.
Ladies and gentlemen,
all the information and the science behind all this stuff.
Is that on at.com o n n I t,
use a codename Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off,
but we can't give any more money off the kettlebells because there is cheap as
we can sell them.
You can't get any better battle ropes he kicked.
Get any cheaper battery rubs.
Go get them.
You 30 pitches it on a.com look at this shock.
The plus is the greatest thing of all time.
We add it here.
Thank you.
Do mortal technique.
Follow him on Twitter and mortal tech.
T e c h on Twitter and file.
Brian Red Band Red v a n death squad.
Super show Friday night,
10 30 here at the Ice House with Mad Flavor,
Aka Joey Diaz,
right Brian Red Band right in front of me.
Josh McDermitt,
our pal originally from Phoenix,
Arizona.
Which show was he on?
What does that show again?
Which shows Josh on.
He's not a show or retired at 35 I think it was.
Well,
we'll find out when we see him.
He'll be on the ice house chronicles as well,
which is only available on desk squad on iTunes.
So go check that out.
We love you guys and we'll see you tomorrow with Robb Wolf,
the adventure of the Paleo Diet Friday.
It's Maynard from tool Holla.
I see you all in August when I come back for his tour and mortal technique
lives.
Gentleman who will return whoever's sleep,
your
okay,
whoa man,
nevermind.
Don't sweet
kid.